YEAH. WE'RE YEAH YEAH YEAH SO.
OKAY. YEAH SO ASSEMBLY RIGHT
RIGHT. OF THIS TICKET OR. YEAH
PUT THIS ALL TOGETHER. HE WILL
GET HIS. IT SHOULD BE THE ONE
THING ON. THE YEAH YEAH. THE
RUN AROUND YEAH I HAVE A LOT OF
THE DIFFERENT. OKAY ACTUALLY.
WHICH IS THROUGH THE- OKAY. BUT
IF YOU HAVE A GROUP CLIP OKAY
SECOND SLICE OF. WHAT'S YOUR-
YEAH. SHE'S. MR STONE REMEMBER
CHECK RESULT YES I THINK I WAS
HERE LAST. YEAH. HOW ARE YOU
GOOD MORNING YEAH. SEE YOU
AGAIN. AFTER YEAH HI I'M JUST
TO THE. RIGHT YEAH. RIGHT IT'S
GOOD TO PUT RIGHT ADDRESS YEAH
BUT WHAT COMING UP YEAH. GOING
TO CALL AND IT. GOOD FOR. LOCAL
ABOUT. WELL IT IS. OKAY RIGHT I
CAN ALSO I DON'T REMEMBER HOW
ARE YOU OKAY GOOD THING YOU.
THE PEOPLE OF THAT STUFF. YEAH.
YEAH OR. WE WILL BE ABLE. HI
BIG YEAH YEAH. YEAH. SO WHAT I.
ACTUALLY I THINK- WILL AFTER
THE OPENING STATEMENT BEFORE OR
POLITICS BUT FIRST CAME OKAY.
OKAY BUT WE GO LOOK AT EAH.
AND YOU CAN GO AHEAD GOOD LUCK
WITH THAT. GROW THAT AND- THE
ONE. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THAT IS ON BEHALF OF
BUDGETS OF FIVE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY THE ASSEMBLY IS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE TODAY IS HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE ACCESS ESPECIALLY
FOR UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS WE
KNOW THAT THAT ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IS BEEN A KEY ISSUE WE
DISCUSSED BUT AS WE DISCUSS
GRAMS IN WORKING BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE DID YOU BRANCH.
THAT NOTION THAT JUSTICE IS AND
SHOULD BE FOR EVERYONE IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK ALL OF
US HERE THE REASON WE'RE HERE.
HOLD THEIR DEAR TO OUR HEARTS
BUT THE PRACTICAL REALITIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO ACCESS
TO JUSTICE SYSTEM REALLY ARE
ARE QUITE DIFFERENT THAN THAT.
SO WAR TRY TO LOOK AT TODAY'S
IS COLLECT AS MUCH INFORMATION
AS WE CAN. ABOUT WHAT THE
SYSTEM CURRENTLY LOOKS AT WHAT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGE ARE
UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS. THE
THROUGH AND- THE COURTS AND
THAT THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING
THE SERVICES WHAT THEY STRUGGLE
WITH WITH ENSURING THAT. THAT
EVERYONE HAS THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THAT'S REALLY THE QUESTION HERE
I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN. DIVE
DEEPLY INTO IT POSE MUCH
INFORMATION FROM A INCREDIBLE
GROUP OF PANELISTS HERE. AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. AND LOOK AT
BETTER WAYS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH OUR POP THE
ARM AS WELL AS OUR BUDGET ARE.
CAN ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING THE BEST ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR CALIFORNIANS CROSS.
ECONOMICS BUT- ACROSS ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE THE
DIVERSITY THAT WE PRIDE
OURSELVES IN CALIFORNIA. NOW
THIS COMMITTEE IS ALSO LOOKED
AT THAT DIVERSITY QUESTION ON
THE BENCH AT THE BAR. AND THOSE
LEADING IN AND THE NUMBER
LAWYERS WHO THE LAWYERS ALL.
WHAT ALL THOSE ARE ARE ARE A
PART OF PARCEL TO THE BROADER
QUESTION OF OUR- SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT VARIOUS PIECES OF IT
AS WE CAN. ALONG THE WAY ALWAYS%
WITH AN EYE TO GIVING PEOPLE
THE JUSTICE THAT THAT THEY SO
DESERVE IN IN THE SYSTEMS THAT
WE SET UP. SO LOGISTICALLY. I'M
GONNA CALL UP PANELS I'M GONNA
ASK TAT DID THAT EACH PANEL
PRESENTS AND THEN OPEN IT UP.
FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS AT
THE END OF THE DAY THERE WILL
BE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S A PUBLIC COMMENT SIGN
UP SHEET SO IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO THIS YOU ARE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO BUT LET US KNOW
WHO YOU ARE. BY SIGNING UP AND
THEN FOR THOSE WE ALSO HAVE
LOTS OF PRESENTATIONS AND HAND
OUT HERE. FOR TO HAVE HAND OUTS
IF YOU HAD GOT WAS ALREADY.
THESE WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE
THINGS TRONIC WEIGHT SO THOSE
OF US WHO ARE. TRYING
DESPERATELY TO BE PAPERLESS
HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYTHING WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THESE DOCUMENTS GET PUT UP. ON
OUR WEBSITE AS WELL MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL THE MEMBERS
OF. BOTH COMMITTEES THAT
ACTUALLY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ANYBODY WHO'S
INTERESTED IN THE OUTCOMES FOR
THIS HEARING. SO WE TRY TO MAKE
THIS INFORMATION. AS AVAILABLE
AS POSSIBLE AND I KNOW
COLLECTING THINGS WITH THE
EARLY WE CAN GET. ELECTRONIC
COPIES AND GET THOSE OUT TO
FOLKS THAT. THE EASIER THAT
GOING TO BE. SO WHAT I'M GOING
TO NOW TURN. TO THE COACH OF
THIS HEARING. THAT IS WEBER. IS
CHAIR OF BUDGET SUB. HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WE AVE
SOMEHOW WORKED IT OUT WHERE THE
CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY. MYSELF
CHAIR OF JUDICIARY JOIN SHIRLEY
WEBER AND TOM LACKEY AND OTHERS
ON PUBLIC SAFETY. BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO WE DO HAVE A
UNIQUE ABILITY TO LOOK ACROSS.
POLICY AS WELL AS BUDGET
QUESTIONS AS WE WRESTLE WITH
THESE AND OTHER IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS. FOR THAT FOR OUR
COMMITTEES AND FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK THAT
UNIQUE LOOK LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE HEARINGS TODAY AND I'M A
TURNOVER FOR ANY OPENING
STATEMENT YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
DOCTOR EVER. THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR A- THE CARING-
THIS EVENT AND BASICALLY
ORGANIZING IT ON ON BEHALF OF
BOTH OF OUR COMMITTEES I
APPRECIATE THAT- FREDERICK
DOUGLAS ONCE SAID THAT WERE
JUSTICE IS DENIED- WERE POVERTY
IS ENFORCED AND WHERE.
IGNORANCE PREVAILS AND WERE
ANYONE CLASSES MADE TO FEEL
THAT SOCIETY IS AN ORGANIZED
CONSPIRACY TOOL PRESS ROB AND
THE GRADE THEM. NEITHER PERSONS
NOR PROPERTY WILL BE SAFE-
THERE'S NO HIGHER STATE THEN
THE PERSON MUST INTERACT WITH
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. SOME AND IT
PERFECT THEM. WE'RE DO YOU DO
CAN BE AT STAKE ARE PRETTY OUR
FAMILY AND OUR PROPERTY. I
THINK THE AS WE DID TALK ABOUT
THAT SEE IN SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT ACCESS TO JUSTICE HELP
TO BRIDGE THE GAP SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET A- FAIR SHAKE.
WHEN THEY DID IT WITH THE
TRADITIONAL PROCESS. WHERE THE
WISHES YOU COULD NOT MUCH OF
THE WEB LOW INCOME. AND TOOK A
HOUR BUS TO GET TO I. TO COURT
WHETHER YOU ARE A WEALTHY IN
CAME WITH ATTORNEYS THESE FACTS
SHOULD HAVE NO. QUALITY OF YOUR
IT. WE THE WHAT'S- IT WAS IT IN
THE MOVIE JUST TO MERCY I MADE
UP OF FOR READING THE BOOK IT'S
SOME IT'S FOR TO HELP FOR KERRY
OUR LIVES ARE WITH REGARD WHEN
IT TO JEFF IF AT NOT HONEST IN
AMPLE. OF THE PROCESS OF THE
LAWS THAT ARE THERE SO- ARE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WE'VE
SUPPORTED A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS
TO HELP ENHANCE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ALL CORD USES INCLUDING
FUNDING SELF HELP CENTERS OF
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY BUT IN
COURT. REPORTERS IN FAMILY
COURT IN EXPECTING LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND SERVICES AND FUNDING
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY TO
PROMOTE GREATER EFFICIENCY WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS
IN THIS BOOK BUT SESSION AS
WELL SO ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER STONE IN THIS
FOR PUTTING THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE TO. AS I PUT THIS WE KNOW
MORE FRIGHTENING BUT I'VE.
GOING INTO COURT AND FOR
UNPREPARED BEING ON A WAY OF
THE- THIS TO TAKE. AND THAT YOU
MAY KNOW GET A FEW SHAKE. I
APPALLED AT THE HOW MANY
PERSONS HAVE TO NAVIGATE THIS
WORLD ALONE- BUT ALSO-
SOMETIMES I'M IMPRESSED WITH
THE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
KNOWLEDGE FOLKS HAVE ACQUIRED
IT ON THEIR OWN. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO. AND I'VE EVEN AT
PERSONS CALL ME BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THAT I HAD A BILL THAT WAS
RELATED TO SOMETHING CORD TO
REMIND MYSELF THE BILL FIVE A
SIX OH. AND YET CALLING ME
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO LIMIT THAT
WITH REGARD TO THE LOVE ONE.
RUN OUT OF RESOURCES THEY DON'T
HAVE MONEY THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND IT'S REALLY AMAZING
HOW MUCH FOLKS HAPPEN.
BASICALLY DO IT ALONE AND- THAT
IN ITSELF IS VERY FRIGHTENING
TO ME SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
I HAVE TO MAKE THIS THIS
EXPERIENCE. OF A LOT EASIER.
AND A LOT MORE CALM FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO IN A CASE
WITH THE- THE COURT SYSTEM AB
IS SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD. WE
DON'T WANT ANYONE AFRAID GO TO.
THE THEY'D FEEL AND- OR THEY
FEEL THAT THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY
OUT TO GET THEM AND
OVERWHELMED. IS WHAT HAPPENS SO
OFTEN AND THEN THEY DON'T SHOW
UP AT ALL. SO I THANK YOU FOR
THIS WITH A COULD WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA HAS. ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND THAT WE SET THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR THE NATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. Q. ANY. OTHER
MEMBERS LIKE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT THIS REST. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I A AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
AND JUST MERCY I THINK DOES-
TELLS A WHOLE LOT MORE ABOUT
WHAT ACCESS TO JUSTICE REALLY
MEANS I THINK THAT. KNOWING
THAT WE HAVE ACTUAL JUSTICE AND
TO SOMETHING THAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT IN THE DOCUMENTS WERE
GIVEN TO US. IT ISN'T JUST A
CONCEPT WE HAVE TO HAVE ACTUAL
JUSTICE- THE THAT DOCUMENTS
ALSO TALK ABOUT THIS ON GOING
JUSTICE CRISIS. AND IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR SO LONG- WE DO
KNOW THE FOR THOSE OF US WHO
ARE ATTORNEYS I THINK JUST
ABOUT EVERY ATTORNEY ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SPENT LOTS OF
TIME WITH THE LEGAL AID-
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. WE HAVE BEEN-
GIVEN A LICENSE TO PRACTICE LAW
LOTS OF PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY FOR AN
ATTORNEY- BUT THEY HAVE AFTER
SPENDING ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
AS A VOLUNTEER WITH OUR INLAND
EMPIRE LOOKING LAWYERS LEGAL
AID I RECOGNIZE HOW VALUABLE.
THAT SERVICE IS TOWARD
COMMITTEE AND ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO CONTINUE TO FUND. OUR
LEGAL AIDS- I THINK SHOULD BE
AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST OUR LAW
THE LIBRARIES WE KNOW OUR
PROVIDING LOTS OF SERVICES. TO
OUR COMMUNITIES- I'M SURPRISED
THAT SEPARATE DEALS IS A LITTLE
BIT LOWER THAN WHAT I WOULD
HAVE EXPECTED- IT THERE THERE
ARE CERTAIN. POPULATIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR STATE THAT
HAVE A GREATER DIFFICULTY
ACCESSING. LEGAL RESOURCES ARE
ONE OF THOSE IS OUR TRIBES. OUR
TRIBE TRIBES IN OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES OUR CHILDREN THAT
ARE PUT THROUGH THE PROCESS WHO
ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEIR TRIBES RATHER. THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN THE I'VE THAT IS
AN ISSUE IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
BEING ADDRESSED IN EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE AND I'M PROUD TO BE
THE AUTHOR OF THAT. ARE
VICTIMS- IN THE ICE DETENTION
CENTERS ALSO- DON'T HAVE GOOD
REPRESENTATION WE DO KNOW THE
STATISTICS ARE CLEAR. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE LEAGUE PRISON. YOUR
ANSWERS OF SIXTY MUCH. AT THIS
TO JUST MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND
I HOPE THAT WE AS WILL BE TALK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
PROVIDING ACCESS. ADEQUATE TO
JUSTICE- THAT WE MOVE TOWARDS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY DOES LOOK
LIKE JUSTICE FOR ALL. I THANK
YOU FOR PUTTING THIS- VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS. THIS
LACKEY YEAH I JUST REAL QUICKLY
I. I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT I
THINK WE ALL HAVE. LEARN FROM
OUR HISTORY AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
TRY TO KEEP A SENSE OF BALANCE
I BELIEVE THAT JUSTICE SHOULD
ACTUALLY. BE SYNONYMOUS WITH
FAIRNESS. AND I THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD BE OR GOAL. AND WE
CAN'T BE ON. BLINDED COMPLETELY
BY. FOCUSING ON ON THE
OFFENDERS WE ALSO HAVE TO KEEP
IN MIND ARE VICTIMS. AND WE
NEED TO HAVE GO SEEK AFTER
TRUTH. AND SEEK FOR FAIRNESS
AND I THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE
GOAL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM. ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEM
BETTER AND I DO BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN IN. THANK YOU. MISTER I
JUST BRIEFLY I WANT TO THANK
THE TEACHERS IN THEIR TEENS FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK. ALL THE
PRISONERS WERE BEING HERE. TO
SHARE WITH US- YOUR YOUR-
EXPERIENCES IN YOUR YOUR
INFORMATION. ALL I WAS A LAW
PRACTICE FOR ABOUT EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND I OVER THE YEARS I
NOTICED A- HOW DIFFICULT IS
I'VE RUNNING TOO MANY PEOPLE
WHO REPRESENT THEMSELVES. AND I
REALIZE HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM. AND IT'S A
REALLY HELPS THE HOUSE SOME YOU
KNOW A LAWYER REPRESENTING THEM
SO. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. TO JUST BE
VERY BRIEFLY AND I WASN'T ABLE
TO HEAR THE PRIOR COMMENTS ARE
PUSH I. APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING
ANY CONTEXT BUT- LIKE ALL OF US
I THINK WE ALL. BELIEVE IN IN.
THE RIGHT TO JUSTICE. THROUGH
REPRESENTATION- AND IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND RIVERS AGO
BEFORE I JOINED THE
LEGISLATURE. WE STYLISH OUR
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AS- AN
ASPIRATIONAL CITY- THAT WOULD
PROVIDE RIGHT TO CIVIL COUNCIL
FOR EVERY LEAD TO GET- WHO- WAS
ABOUT TO BE DEPRIVE. SOME
SIGNIFICANT- TO PROCESS OR
LIBERTY- IN THE CONTEXT OF
EVICTIONS IMMIGRATION
PROCEEDINGS. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROCEEDINGS AND OTHERS. I AND-
I UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO BE IN
AND OUT OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BUT FOR. THE WITNESSES WHO COME
UP IF THERE ARE PERSPECTIVES ON
WHAT CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED TO
DO. TO REALLY ACHIEVE THAT.
COULD CALIFORNIA. BECOME THE
FIRST STATE IN THE COUNTRY TO
SAY. TO EVERY LOW INCOME LET
AGAIN. YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO
COUNSEL IN WHAT CONTEXT HOW
WOULD WE DO THAT. LOVE SOME
PERSPECTIVES ON THAT. ANYONE
ELSE ANY OTHER MEMBER OPENING
STATEMENTS. ALL RIGHT THIS CALL
UP THE FIRST PANEL. SO THE
FIRST PANEL IS TALKING ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA HEY WE
HAVE HELEN HONG THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF ACCESS INCLUDES
AT THE STATE BAR. WE HAVE JUDGE
JONI PRESIDENT PRESIDING FAMILY
LAW JUDGE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND LEAH SIMON WEISBERG
DIRECTING ATTORNEY FOR THE
SHELTER CLIENTS ADVOCATES
PROGRAM. OF THE PART OF THE
FICTION DEFENSE COLLABORATIVE.
WELCOME. THANK. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS HELEN HONG
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF AXIS OF INCLUSION AT THE
STATE BAR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND TO LAY
SOME GROUNDWORK FOR YOUR
CONVERSATION FOR THIS MORNING.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BAR IS
COMMITTED TO INCREASING ACCESS
TO AN INCLUSION IN THE LEGAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND WITH THAT
WE ACTUALLY COMPLETED THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE GAP STUDY
JUST LAST MONTH AND I WILL
PRESIDING THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
THAT STUDY TODAY. LIST JUSTICE
GAP STUDY ACTUALLY INCLUDED
FOUR COMPONENTS THE FIRST OF
WHICH WAS A FOUR THOUSAND
PERSON. SURVEY OF CALIFORNIANS
CONDUCTED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO'S NATIONAL OPINION
RESEARCH CENTER. THEY ARE THE
SAME INSTITUTION THAT CONDUCTED
THE LEGAL SERVICES CORPORATION
NATIONAL LSE JUSTICE CAP STUDY
A TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WE CLOSELY
MODELED OUR SURVEY WITH THE FEW
VARIABLES FIRST WE FOCUSED ON
THE EXPERIENCE OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MAKING
LESS THAN THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR WITH
A FAMILY OF FOUR. THAT IS
CONSIDERED 125% OF POVERTY AND
THAT MAKES THESE HOUSEHOLD
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE LEGAL
SERVICES THROUGH LEGAL AIDS
SUPPORTED BY THE STATE BAR OF
CALIFORNIA. SECONDLY WE OVER
SAMPLE POPULATIONS THAT WORKS
BETTER SPEAKING. RURAL AREAS
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT. THOSE THAT
SERVED IN THE MILITARY
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AS WELL AS LOOKING AT RURAL
AREAS BY CENSUS TRACK. WHAT WE
REALLY WANTED TO SEE IS WHAT IS
THE EXPERIENCE OF CALIFORNIANS
WHEN THEY ENCOUNTER PROBLEMS.
THAT HAVE A CIVIL LEGAL REMEDY
SO WE WEREN'T ASKING WHERE YOU
A PLAINTIFF IN THE ACTION WERE
YOU A DEFENDANT IN THE ACTION
WE ASKED WERE YOU A VETERAN AND
WHEN YOU WERE DESTROYED YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET YOUR JOB
BACK. HAVE YOU BEEN HARASSED BY
COLLECTION AGENCIES WERE YOU
MISS BUILT FOR MEDICAL
PROCEDURES THAT WERE COVERED BY
YOUR INSURANCE. ARE YOU BEING-
WERE YOU OF LOSING A HEALTH
BASED ON FORECLOSURE. AND SO
THESE WERE A BROAD GAMUT OF
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE A CIVIL
LEGAL REMEDIES OFTEN BEFORE
THOSE FIRST SEVEN PAPERS GET TO
YOUR DOOR. SO ALONG WITH THAT
AT THE SAME TIME WE SURVEYED
THE SIXTY NINE LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BETTER SUPPORTED BY THE
STATE BAR TO UNDERSTAND WHO
WERE COMING TO YOUR DOORS WHAT
WERE THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY
WERE FACING AND IN YOUR
ESTIMATE HOW WELL WERE YOU ABLE
TO RESOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS.
ALONG WITH THAT WE INCLUDED KEY
FINDINGS OF THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA'S
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION STUDY
TO UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES OF
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS WERE
PROVIDED THE CRUCIAL WORK. OF
SERVING THOSE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. AND UNDERSTANDING
WHAT. THE PIPELINE INTO LEGAL
AID LOOKS LIKE WE SURVEYED
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE SOUTH TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED LAW STUDENTS FROM
CALIFORNIA. TO UNDERSTAND HOW
LAW SCHOOL DEBT IMPACTS CAREER
CHOICE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
INFLUENCE OF A LOWER PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. TWO OF
INFLUENCE OF FUTURE LEGAL AID
CAREERS BUILT SPECIFICALLY
PUBLIC INTEREST. SO THE KEY
FINDINGS TO NO ONE'S SURPRISE
IN THE ROOM MOST CALIFORNIA
HELPFUL- EXPERIENCING ONCE A
LEGAL ISSUE IN THE YEAR. FOR
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES THAT'S
THREE TIMES AS MANY PROBLEMS.
FOR SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE
EXPERIENCE EIGHT TIMES AS MANY
PROBLEMS. FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE AVERAGE IS FOUR
POINT THREE WHEREAS FOR OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS IT'S TWO POINT ONE
SO THE EXPERIENCE MORE PROBLEMS
AS THEY GO AS THEY- INDIVIDUALS
HAVE LESS INCOME. NOW FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
INCOME HEALTH FINANCE AND
EMPLOYMENT WERE THE MOST COMMON
TYPES OF LEGAL PROBLEMS
FAMILIES EXPERIENCED. SO THEY
HAD MORE OF THOSE IN TERMS OF
FREQUENCY. NOW REGARDLESS OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT FAMILIES
EXPERIENCE TO LESS THAN ONE IN
THREE ACTUALLY EVEN THOUGHT
LEGAL HELP. LIKE DR WEBER SAID
MOST CALIFORNIANS WILL ASK
FAMILY AND FRIENDS BEFORE THEY
SEEK LEGAL HELP WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS THE- SOMETHING IN
TERMS OF THEIR JUST THE
KNOWLEDGE GAP NOT EVEN KNOWING
TAT THE ISSUE MAY HAVE A CIVIL
LEGAL REMEDY. OR THAT THEY NEED
A LAWYER FOR THE LEGAL
INFORMATION. SECONDLY BASED ON
THE INTAKE CENSUS WE THINK THAT
LEGAL AID CAN ONLY FULLY
RESOLVED ONE THIRD OF ALL THE
PROBLEMS THAT COME TO THEIR
DOOR. BASED ON A LACK OF
RESOURCES ALONG WITH STAFFING
AND OTHER CHALLENGES ONE THIRD
THEY CAN EVEN EVEN HELP AT ALL.
ONE THIRD THE CAN PARTIALLY
SERVE ABOUT ONE THIRD THEY CAN
FULLY RESERVE SERVE. WE SEE
THAT ONE THIRD OF LEGAL AID
ATTORNEYS ARE LEAVING THE
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN TWO YEARS.
FINANCIAL SALARIES ARE THE
NUMBER ONE REASON FINANCIAL
STRUCTURES. WHICH LEADS INTO
THE BLAST FINDING WHICH IS 80%
OF ALL AB A CALIFORNIA LAW
STUDENTS ANTICIPATE GRADUATING
WITH A HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF LAW SCHOOL
DEBT. THAT'S A MEDIAN SO HALF
WILL HAVE MORE THAN THAT AND
HALF WILL HAVE LESS THAN THAT.
MOVING INTO WHAT DOES THE
JUSTICE GAP LOOK LIKE AT THE
JUSTICE GAP AS WE DEFINE IT.
ART WHAT ARE THE CIVIL LEGAL
PROBLEMS THAT LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING
AND WHAT ARE THE RESOURCE TO
MEET THOSE NEEDS. THE LEFT FOR
SHOWS THE GAP FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO QUALIFY FOR
FREE LEGAL SERVICES AT ABOUT
EIGHTY SIX PERCENT. WHAT I
WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE IS THAT THIS GAP PROCESS
THAT IS HIGHER FOR EVEN INCOMES
UP 23100% OF POVERTY. BUT IS
ACTUALLY PROCESS REGARDLESS OF
YOUR INCOME. IN TERMS OF.
ACCESSING LEGAL SERVICES. NOW
WHEN WE LOOK AT WHEN PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE LEGAL PROBLEMS AND
WE ASK THEM ALL WANTING TO SEEK
LEGAL HELP IT GOES TO THE MANY
QUESTIONS THAT- PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY OFFERED AMONG THIS
COMMITTEE. THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE LEGAL ISSUE. FOR MANY
PROBLEMS THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE LEGAL ISSUE. LIKE DR WEBER
SAID PEOPLE JUST ARE DEALING IT
WITH ALL ON THEIR OWN. BUT HAD
THEY KNON BELIEVE FULL
RAMIFICATIONS THEY MAY HAVE
BEHAVED DIFFERENTLY. THE ALSO
THE ISSUES OF NOT KNOWING WHERE
TO GO FEAR ABOUT COST IN FEAR
ABOUT RETALIATION OR FEAR ABOUT
LITIGATION IS ALSO. A FACTOR. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND IN
TERMS OF. THE TYPES OF KEPT
HELP CALIFORNIANS ARE RECEIVING
OFFLINE SO IN PERSON VERSUS
ONLINE. IS A VARIETY OF SOURCES.
PARTICULARLY ONLINE PEOPLE ARE
JUST LOOKING FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT THE PROCEDURE THE PROCESS
THE RIGHTS JUST TRYING TO
BASICALLY NAVIGATE WHAT ARE.
THE POSSIBLE AVENUES THEY CAN
TAKE IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT TYPES OF
PROBLEMS CALIFORNIANS ARE
ACTUALLY SEEKING LEGAL HELP
AGAIN THIS IS ONLY THE ONE IN
THREE THAT REALLY EVEN SEEKING
LEGAL HELP AND THEN RECEIVING
LEGAL HELP WE SEE A SLIGHT
SHIFT IN TERMS OF THE BEHAVIOR-
THESE ARE CATEGORIES IN WHICH
CALIFORNIANS WILL ACTUALLY
STATE THESE PROBLEMS HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL OR SEVERE IMPACT ON
THEIR LIVES. CUSTODY FAMILY LAW
HOMEOWNERSHIP. IMMIGRATION AND
SO THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO NOT
ONLY THINK LEGAL SERVICES BUT
ALSO RECEIVE THEM BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THESE ARE ALSO THE
SAME CATEGORIES IN WHICH MOST
PEOPLE THINK I NEED A LAWYER
FOR THAT. SO THAT GOES THE
KNOWLEDGE GAP. THE LAST MY LAST
SLIDE IS BASED ON- WHAT ARE THE
SOURCES OF HELP FOR
CALIFORNIANS. YOU WILL SEE FOR
MOST CALIFORNIANS NOT THE MOST
I WOULD SAY. FOR CALIFORNIANS
OVERALL A PAID ATTORNEY IS THE
NUMBER ONE AVENUE HOWEVER. YOU
DON'T KNOW THE AVERAGE COST OF
THE HOURLY RATE FOR ATTORNEY
CALIFORNIA IS THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
IF WE LOOK AT FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE
OF HELP IS LEGAL AID AND WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE FLOODED WE SEE
LEGAL AID WITH OTHER NONPROFITS
AND OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS
LIKE THE COURTS. THEY MAKE UP
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
INFORMATION AND SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIANS OVERALL. SO FOR
NEXT STEPS OF THE STATE BAR IS
ACTUALLY CONDUCTING PHASE TWO
OF THE JUSTICE GAP STUDY. TO
ISSUE THE SURVEY IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES TO UNDERSTAND HOW A
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
CALIFORNIANS NAVIGATE THE
SIMILAR PROBLEMS AND THE
COURTS- WERE ALSO GETTING INPUT
FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO
JUSTICE LEGAL AID COMMISSION.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON THE
REPORT ITSELF AT THE CHINA THE
PERMISSION WITH ARE LEGALLY
COMMUNITY AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WE'RE LOOKING INTO THE DATE
A LITTLE BIT MORE TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW
CALIFORNIANS BEHAVE BASED ON
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. YOU NEXT TO JOIN
THANK YOU MY IS BILL MEAL ONE I
AM THE SUPER JUDGE ALL FOUND
IMPROVE HERE AT THE
SACRAMENTO'S COURT IN FAMILY
LAW WE HAVE NINE DEDICATED
FAMILY LAW. JUDGES WHAT I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS TO YOU IS THE
ROLE OF THE SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS IN FAMILY LAW
POSSIBLY 75% OF THE DID CONSENT
WE SELL OFF OF REPRESENTATIVE.
AND THAT MEANS THE MAJORITY OF
THE POPULATION IS ALSO INDIGENT.
THAT'S A STAGGERING NUMBER WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THE ISSUES THAT WE
ADJUDICATE EVERY DAY ON THE
TREMENDOUS TROT TIME
CONSTRAINTS OTHER THAN
TROPICAL- FAMILY LITTLE
COURTHOUSE IS THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS. THEIR EXPERIENCE IT
BY MIDDLE. INFLUENCES THE WAY
THEY LOOK AND WE GOT AT THE
LEGAL SYSTEM AS A WHOLE. THE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE JUDICATA FOR
THEM MAY SEEM INSIGNIFICANT BUT
FOR THEM IT'S LIFE ALTERING ITS
LIFE AND DEATH. I WHEN WE ARE
CONSIDERING THIS PARTICULAR
CONTINGENT POPULATION WE GOT A
LOOK AT WHEN THEY COME TO
FAMILY LAW. THA THEY HAD
COMING WITH THE EMOTIONS. WHICH
IS WHAT MAKES FAMILIES ALSO
DIFFICULT IS THE LOSS OF A
RELATIONSHIP. IS THE
DISAPPOINTMENT. IF THE CDVA. IS
THE LOSS OF CONTROL THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE OVERRIDING FEAR THAT
THEY HAVE IS OF LOS CONTROL A
COMPOST BUILT THE PERSON TO SEE
THINGS MY WAY THERE MUST BE A
SOLUTION AN INTERVENTION. AND
SO WHEN THEY REACHED THE
IMPASSE THEY COME TO THE FAMILY
LOCAL OF BELIEVING THAT THE
WEAKER RESULTS SOME OF THEIR
PROBLEMS. THEY NERVOUS THIS
STRESS. AND THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
THE COURTHOUSE BOOKS BUT THEY
DO KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT THEY
CAN COME TO GET RELIEF SO WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
THE IF THE LAWS ARE ACTUALLY
BRING TO THE COURTHOUSE. FOR
RESOLUTIONS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ALWAYS LOOK AT HIS
PROPERTY ISSUES. GEN THE TIME
THAT THEY WERE TOGETHER THEIR
MATH THIS PROPERTY. THEY HAVE
THIS JOINT VENTURE THEY HAD
THIS JOINT VISION THE BUSINESS
THAT WE ACQUIRED TOGETHER THE
HOUSE THAT WE PURCHASED. THE
BUT THAT I SOLD MY HOUSE LITTLE
OWN PEOPLE MANAGER THAT PUT THE
MONEY INTO THE COMMUNITY HOUSE.
WE GOT TO DECIDE AND DIVIDE UP
THE PROPERTY DETERMINE HOW WITH
FINAL PORTION RETIREMENT
BENEFITS. DECIDED WE GOT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO BANK
ACCOUNTS THERE WAS THE
FINANCIAL STUFF IN THE WITH THE
OTHER SPOUSE THAT DEFERRED THAT
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT TO THE
OTHER SPOUSE. NOW THAT WITHOUT
SEPARATION SOMETHING IS TO
DECIDE HOW TO EQUALIZE THAT
ACCESS. CHILDREN THE CHILDREN
OF EARLY OFTEN THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO COME OUT OF
THAT RELATIONSHIP I WHEN THEY
CANNOT AGREE IT CREATES
TREMENDOUS BE CONTENT
TREMENDOUS CONCERN FOR THEY
COME TO FAMILY COURT HOUSE TO
RESOLVE THE IMPASSE BUT THEY'VE
REACH THAT'S BECAUSE WHO GETS
CUSTODY HOW OFTEN CAN I GET TO
SEE MY CHILDREN UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES DO I SEE MY
CHILDREN WHY SHOULD I HAVE TO
SAY HAVE A SUPERVISED
VISITATION. AND THEN THE
DIFFICULT CASES THAT WE DEAL
WITH BECAUSE WE ALL MOBILE
SOCIETY WE MOVE ON I MARRY
SOMEBODY WHO HAPPENS TO LIVE IN
NEW YORK WE SHOULD CUSTODY BUT
NOW I HVE TO I'M OFTEN TO BE
RELOCATE THREE JUDGES IN FAMILY
LAW AFTER JUDICATA RELOCATION
CASES THAT FOREVER CHANGES THE
DYNAMICS. OF THIS FAMILY. AND
WHEN FAMILIES BREAK ALL POLL
PARTNERS DISSOLVE THE
RELATIONSHIP. WE HAVE TO
COLLECT WITH THEM AS WE HAVE
THE FAMILY MEMBERS THE
GRANDPARENTS AND THE RELATIVE
BUT TYPICALLY GRANDPARENTS I
USED TO BE INVOLVED IN MY
CHILDREN AND MY GRANDCHILDREN
FLIGHTS. WE MAY HAVE TO JOIN
THOSE PARTIES TO THIS
PROCEEDING. SO THESE OLDER THAN
I WAS THAT WE ADDRESS IN TERMS
OF CUSTOMER VISITATION BUT THEN
AS THE FINANCIAL ASPECT. THEY
SAY THAT FINANCIAL ISSUES CAN
BE ONE OF THE DRIVING FORCES
THAT SCHOOLS PARTY'S THE
SEPARATE. BUT IS COMPOUNDED NOW
BECAUSE NOW IF I HAVE ONE
INCOME I HAVE TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHO PAYS
CHILD SUPPORT. WHAT IS THE
OBLIGATION BUT YOU HAVE TO WAS
YOUR FORMER SPOUSE YOUR FORMAL
PARTNER. I HAVE TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO THE DREAM
THAT WE HAD THAT I COULD BE THE
HOMEMAKER UNTIL OUR CHILDREN
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL. THAT
MAYBE WHAT PART IS OFTEN THE
OTHER PARTY NOT TO GO TO WORK.
SHOULD THAT BE IMPUTED INCOME.
IS ONE PARTY ON THE PERFORMANCE
ON ON IN THIS OF BIG. AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE. TO TAKE.
ESTIMATES POLICY. ON BEST MAYBE
THE LAW. GOING THAT WE- WHEN
THE PROTESTANT A NUMBER OF. AND
IN THE TO MISTER BONUSES.ORDER
MAKE IT THE TO. AS TO WHAT THE
SHOULD EXCLUDED FROM THE HOW.
SOMEBODY SHOULD BE RESTRAINED
CON WITH THE- AND HOW LONG THAT
RESTRAINING ORDER WILL LOST.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THESE
DECISIONS ARE LIKE WALDRON TO
THE FAMILY UNIT. I'M NOT JUST
THE LITTLE DISRUPTION. I
BECAUSE OF THE CONSEQUENTIAL
NATURE OF THESE ISSUES IS BEEN
FIT BUT IN FAMILY LAW. A
JUDGE'S PEN IS MIGHTIER THAN
ANY SORT. AND IT'S BECAUSE THE
FAMILY LAW JUDGES VESTED WITH
VAST DISCUSSION. GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH YOU WOULD ASK
YOURSELF WHY WOULD ANYBODY WANT
TO SELF REPRESENT. OBVIOUSLY
THE OFFICE ON FIFTY THING TO BE
REAL PROCEED COST- MY COLLEAGUE
HAS SPOKEN AFTER THAT. AND THEN
AS THE PERCEPTION THAT THE
COURT WILL DO THE RIGHT THING A
LAWYER WILL NOT. UNABLE TO
AFFORD REPRESENTATION 65% OF
OUR POPULATION OF THE 75% THE
COME TO THE FAMILY LOCAL HOUSE
INDIGENT SUBJECT TO BE WITH US.
THAT COMPLICATED. IT MAY BE A
GENERAL MISTRUST OF THE LEGAL
SYSTEM. AND THEN WE ALSO CITE
THIS TREND TOWARD SELF HELP.
THERE'S ALWAYS A YOU TUBE VIDEO
THAT COULD EXPLAIN TO YOU HOW
TO FILL OUT THE FORM. AND HOW
YOU CAN DO IT YOURSELF. I LOVE
THE WAY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONTINGENCIES OF ITS GUNS THE
STATE I'M MY OWN BEST
REPRESENTS TO. THAT BEING THE
CASE. KNOWING THAT I HAVE STILL
PURPOSE INTO THE GUNS ON THE
SITE. OF WHAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONE OF THE SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO THEM. THEIR PRIME CONCERN IS
THAT THEY BEHIND THEY WENT UP
TO TELL THE STORY IN THEIR OWN
LANGUAGE AND IN THE ONLY. WITH
THE DIVERSITY OF LANGUAGES THAT
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA WE FIND
OFTENTIMES WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
HERE IS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
A- AN INTERPRETER THAT HAS THE
RIGHT DOLICHYL THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE. THE OFF THE THIS THE
DIFFERENCES THAT MEANS I HAVE
TO SLOW DOWN. THE WHAT THAT DAY
IN COURT DATE WHICH THE
IMPULSE. THE OPPOSITE MEN AND
THEY ARE EXPECTED BUT WHEN THEY
COME TO COURT THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A NEUTRAL
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE PRINCIPAL. AND
WILL APPLY THE RULES
CONSISTENTLY. THEY WANT TO BE
TREATED WITH RESPECT. THAT
MEANS FROM THE MINUTE THEY COME
THROUGH THE DOOR HOME SECURITY
THAT TELLS THEM TO PUT THE- THE
BAGGAGE IS ON THE ON THE
CONVEYOR BELT. TO THE CLIENT
THAT PROCESS THAT PEOPLE WORK
TO THE JUDGE THAT HE HAS THE
CASE. TREAT ME WITH RESPECT.
THE ONE OF BILL THE SYSTEM IS
BETTER THEM. AND THAT MEANS. I
DON'T WANT YOU TO HELP OTHER
PART TOO MUCH. I WANT YOU TO BE
NEUTRAL. I JUST PAID THIS
DOCUMENT PREPARED DOWN THE
ROAD. TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
HELP ME PUT MY PEOPLE WORK
TOGETHER. AND NOW YOU'RE GIVEN
THAT PERSON TOO MUCH HELP. THEY
WANT TO LEAVE THAT COURT
HEARING FEELING THAT THEY
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING COOL THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT COMES NEXT. WHEN
THEY'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BATTLE THEY CALL IT HERE. SO
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE ORDERS
THAT I MAY BE REDUCED TO
WRITING. MAYBE I THINK TO THEM
ON THE PHONE SO THAT THEY CAN
PULL UP A DIGITAL FORM OF THE
ORDERS THAT I MADE FOR THAT
THEY CAN PRODUCE THEM TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO THAT THEY CAN
PRODUCE THEM TO A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT SAYS TO THEM. THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS. SO THEY NEED TO LEAD
CORE WAS SIMPLE CLEAR ORDERS.
THEY WON'T QUALITY PATIENT FEE.
REPEATEDLY COMING INTO COURT
GET THE MOTHER'S CONTINUES
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE COURT
INTERPRETED. GETTING OUT OF
CONTINUE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHO TO SERVE GET THE
MEDICS CONTINUES COME THE
CRISIS THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES ON. PHILOSOPHY THANK
YOU CAN GIVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY
TO THE SHOULD THIS BE WHAT I
KNOW MY TIME IS UP I DON'T HAVE
TO THINK TIME UP SO I CONCLUDED
MYSELF. THANK YOU THANK YOU
JUDGE ALONE. THANK YOU. I KNOW
WE ASK EVERYBODY TO DO VERY
BRIEF PRESENTATIONS. AND AT AT
OF RESPECT FOR THE LENGTH OF
THE HEARING AND FOR EVERYONE I
I'M HOPING FOLKS WILL. WILL
STICK TO THAT. BUT I APPRECIATE
THE PASSION AND- THE
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO GET INTO THIS RECORD AND IF
THERE'S- OTHER THINGS AS WE
FINISH THIS HEARING THAT DIDN'T
GET COVERED. THEY ALWAYS
WELCOME TO SUBMIT MATERIALS WE
WILL PUT THEM UP AND MAKE THEM
A PART OF THE RECORD. SO MS
SEVEN WHISPER. WELCOME YES GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU- I AM THE-
DIRECTING I AM A DOCTORING
ATTORNEY ATAFFECTION DEFENSE
COLLABORATIVE ON THAT IS A
NONPROFIT IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THAT IS ADMINISTERING THE RIGHT
TO COUNSEL PROGRAM FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. BEFORE THAT I WAS
THE- IS MINISTERING THE A
SIMILAR PROGRAM FOR THAT-
ALAMEDA COUNTY. I BRING THAT UP
BECAUSE I WANT FOLKS TO KNOW
THAT OBVIOUSLY THERE MY
EXPERIENCES OF SITUATIONS WHERE
WE HAD LOTS OF REPRESENTATION
AND NOT SO MUCH. I AM HAVE ONE
OF THE UNIQUE EXPERIENCES IN
CALIFORNIA OF HAVING PRACTICE
IN EIGHT DIFFERENT- COUNTIES
AND THOSE ARE ACROSS THE STAT
SO EVERYTHING FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. SAN MATTEO AT SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY BUT ALSO
FRESNO AND- MERCED.
REPRESENTATION OF TENANTS- WHO
ARE FACING EVICTION IS THE
BIGGEST GAME CHANGER- AND I SAY
THAT HAVING REPRESENTED FOLKS
AND I AM ALSO- AN ELECTED RENT
BOARD MEMBER OF THE BERKELEY
RAMP BOARDS SO I AM VERY
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN WHEN YOU
HAVE THE STRONGEST PROTECTIONS.
AND HAVING PRACTICED IN FRESNO
WHERE I ACTUALLY GREW UP- IT
WHERE YOU MAY NOT HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS BUT HAVING AN
ATTORNEY IS WHAT MAKES THE MOST
DIFFERENCE. I'VE SEEN TIENEN
SIGN AGREEMENTS WHERE THEY PAY
BACK NOT ONLY THE RENT BUT-
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN ATTORNEY'S FEES WHEN
THE NOTICE THAT THEY WERE BEING
AFFECTED WITH WAS ABSOLUTELY
BASELESS AND I DON'T MEAN
FACTUALLY I MEAN IT WAS A
DEFECTIVE NOTICE. AND I'VE ALSO
SEEN PEOPLE. AB SO ANYWAY I TO-
SHARE WITH YOU ONE OF THE CASES
THAT- HAS NEVER LEFT ME- THIS
WAS A CASE HAT I A I
REPRESENTED A FAMILY. IN LOS
ANGELES- IN THE- AROUND TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX- AND I THINK
IT REALLY ILLUSTRATES HOW
IMPORTANT REPRESENTATION AS-
THE MOTHER OF THIS FAMILY HAD
DISCOVERED THAT THE HUSBAND HAD
MOLESTED THEIR YOUNGEST CHILD.
SHE DID AN OUT AND AS SOON AS
SHE KNEW THAT SHE DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT SHE
IMMEDIATELY CONTACTED. THE
POLICE SHE- REMOVE THE FAMILY
TO A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTER
SO THAT THE CHILDREN WOULD
IMMEDIATELY BE SAFE. SHE MADE
SURE THE CHILDREN WERE IN
SCHOOL EVERY DAY EVEN THOUGH
THE SHELTER WAS OVER AN HOUR
AWAY FROM THEIR SCHOOL SHE WAS
ABLE TO MAINTAIN SHE MAINTAINED
HER JOB. SHE HAD APPEARED EVERY
HEARING SHE'S REQUESTED SHE
RESPONDED TO EVERY REQUEST MADE
BY SOCIAL WORKERS MAKE SURE HER
CHILDREN WERE IN SOCIAL WORK.
SHE EVEN PAID THE RENT FOR AN
APARTMENT SHE WASN'T ABLE TO
STAND WHILE SHE WAS IN THE
SHELTER. UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS
THE FIRST TIME SHE'D EVER MAIL
FOR RENT AND SUPPOSE THE
ADDRESS SO THE NUMBER WRONG
AND- RETURNED TO HER MAILBOX
THAT SHE ALSO. WASN'T ACCESSING
BECAUSE SHE WAS IN THE SHOP AND
WITH NOT GOING BACK TO THE
PROPER. SHE WHAT THE FINAL
RETURN BECAUSE THE HUSBAND WAS.
AND WAS IN. THREAT TO THE
FAMILY. SHE RETURNED TO FOR. AT
IN EFFECT NOTICE ON HER HER
DOOR WITH AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER
HAD BEEN FILED AND DISCOVERED
THAT THE RENT WAS SITTING- IN
HER MAILBOX. BUT SHE WENT TO
THE LANDLORD WHO REFUSE TO
ACCEPT THE RENT AT THAT TIME.
AND SHE SOUGHT LEGAL SERVICES
AND WAS AN ABLE TO. SHE WENT.
AND SO SHE HAD TO GO TO TRIAL
BY HERSELF SHE HAD TO PREPARE
ANSWER. BY HERSELF- ESSENTIALLY
WAS BLANK SO REYES NO DEFENSES.
AND SHE WENT TO TRIAL AND
BASICALLY SAID PLEASE LET ME
STATE THIS TERRIBLE THING
HAPPENED- I CAN PAY MY RENT
PLEASE LET ME STAY
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT A
DEFENSE AND UNLAWFUL DETAINER
CASE. SHE THEN LOST AND KAY AND
THEN TRY AGAIN TO FIND LEGAL
SERVICES AT THE TIME THAT SHE
GOT THE ACTUAL VACATE NOTICE
WHICH MEANT LIKE THE SHERIFF SO
GONNA CALM AND THEY'RE GOING TO
AFFECT YOU. AND AT THAT POINT
LIKELY SHE CAME TO AN
ORGANIZATION AND- I HAD AN
OPENING THAT DAY AND I HAD THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING HER SHE
TOLD ME ALL OF THESE YOU KNOW
THIS VERY- YOU KNOW I GOT A
STORY THAT. I DIDN'T HEAR OFTEN
BUT YOU KNOW I'LL NEVER FORGET.
AND I OPEN UP ALL HER PAPERWORK
AND THE NOTICES DEFECTIVE THIS
SHOULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED BUT
SHE DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO A
LAWYER TO PREPARE HER
PAPERWORK. AND SHE HADN'T RAISE
THAT I COULDN'T EVEN APPEAL
BECAUSE IT HASN'T HADN'T BEEN
RAISED- AT THE TRIAL. AND IT
WASN'T IN THE ANSWER BUT WHAT I
COULD DO WAS FILE HARDSHIP
MOTION. AND WHICH I HAVE I'VE
REPRESENTED OVER THOUSAND
TENANTS- AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER.
IN THOSE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THREE WHEN I STARTED
REPRESENTING TENANTS AND I HAVE
FILED A THREE. AND BECAUSE THEY
ARE SO DIFFICULT TO- OF- WE
WERE ABLE TO DO AMAZING THINGS
INCLUDING- WE DOOR NOT ALL OF
THE TENANTS ALL TWENTY FIVE OF
THE TENANTS SIGNED DECLARATIONS
SAYING THAT SHE WAS A GOOD
NEIGHBOR. AND THAT SHE WAS PART
OF THE COMMUNITY AND THEY
WANTED HER TO BE ABLE TO COME
BACK. WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
JUST TURNING TO SIGN A
DECLARATION SAYING HOW. ON HOW
HARD SHE HAD WORK TO PROTECT
FAMILY AND- ATTACKED THE
VICTIMS OF A CRIME. IN THE
PROCESS OF ADMINISTERING BUT
JUST AS. AT THE MOTION GRANT.
THIS IS THE CASE THAT NAY
SHOULD HAVE YOU GOTTEN TO THE
POINT BUT I WILL NEVER BE LOST
ON ME WHEN THE MOTHER SAID WHY
IS IT MY HUSBAND HAD A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. AND I COULDN'T GET A
LAWYER. AND I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR THAT EXCEPT I REALLY
HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN
CHANGE REDDING CALIFORNIA AND
THAT WE WILL YOU KNOW THAT IN
THE FUTURE MOTHERS WILL ALWAYS
HAVE- THOSE PROTECTIONS AND
THAT REPRESENTATION. THANK YOU
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION SEVEN
WAYS BERGMAN THAT CAN ASK THESE
ARE THINGS THAT THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SO ARE WE
BETTER OFF FUNDING LEGAL
SERVICES ATTORNEYS WERE SELF
HELP CENTERS. AND WHY FEW ONE
OR THE OTHER NOT THAT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NECESSARILY DO
THAT BUT- JUST TO HELP. TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE I MEAN I WOULD
I WOULD I WOULD SAY IT SHOULD
ALWAYS BE. ALL OF THEM BUT I
THINK THAT THE GAME CHANGER IS
THAT REPRESENTATION I MEAN. I
KNOW FOR MYSELF- YOU KNOW WHEN
I DID A WILL I DIDN'T DO IT
MYSELF AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
I THINK THAT- IT IT IS THAT
REPRESENTATION. AND WE SEE THE-
YOU KNOW WITH PUBLIC DEFENDERS
AND STATES WHERE THERE ARE NO
ATTORNEYS I MEAN THE WHOLE
SYSTEM FALLS APART BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T. IF YOU DON'T HAVE. EVERY
PART OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
PRESENT IT CAN'T FUNCTION IT'S
LIKE HAVE TRYING TO DRIVE A CAR
WITH ONLY THREE WHEELS. AND I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
IN YOU KNOW. IN PLACE I DON'T I
DON'T WANT TO POINT OUT SOME
PARTS OF OUR STATE THAT WE HAVE
CERTAIN STEREOTYPES ABOUT BUT
YOU KNOW THEY'RE JUST PLACES
WHERE TENANTS. VERY VISIBLE OR
THAT THEY HAVE TO DRIVE THREE
HOURS- TO ACCESS SERVICES
BECAUSE WE ARE SERVICES ARE SO
LIMITED. AND THE WAY THEY'RE
TREATED AND THE CONDITIONS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO LIVE UNDER
REALLY- I JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE
REMINDS ME OF THE GREAT.
STARTED TAKING PICTURES OF HOW
PEOPLE REAL AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME. AT THE YOU KNOW WE PASSED
A WRITER HOUSING YOU KNOW AFTER
THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND WE
ADDRESS THAT WE ARE RETURN TO
THAT WAY I HAVE BEEN IN CLIENTS
HOMES THAT. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE
TO LIVE THAT WAY BUT THEY CAN'T
FIGHT THEIR LANDLORDS BECAUSE
THEY THERE'S- A LAW. TO DO THAT
AND THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO NOW
THIS. AT TRIAL SOME AND LAW.
SEE BECAUSE THEY BOTH CLIENTS
THOSE TEN ONE. GET HELP OR A-
AND NO KNOWS I MEAN PART OF IS
ALSO. KEEPING THE SYSTEM HONEST
BECAUSE SO MANY CASES ARE
SETTLED SO THE JUDGE IS NOT
EVEN SEEN KIND OF HOW THESE
THINGS ARE PLAYING OUT THEY'RE
NOT LOOKING AT THE NOTICE THEY
JUST HAVE TO PEOPLE THAT COME
AFTER A COUPLE OF HOURS OF
NEGOTIATING IN THE HALLWAY. AND
THEY JUST SIGN OFF AND THEY GET
CREDIT FOR NOT HAVING A
THOUSAND CASES GO TO TRIAL NOT
DID EACH INDIVIDUAL ONE WAS A
TRUST AND JUDGES AREN'T
SUPPOSED TO BE THE OTHER LAWYER
AT LEAST IN OUR SYSTEM RIGHT
SOME YEAH THEY CAN'T. PART OF
IT OUR SYSTEM IS AN ADVERSARIAL
SYSTEM WHICH PRESUMES THAT BOTH
SIDES ARE REPRESENTED AND
REPRESENT A COMPETENTLY THAT'S
THE ISSUE THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
THE STATE BAR AS WELL WE HAVE
LICENSING AND WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THAT. AND YET BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
INCREASED AND WE ARE ALLOWING
SELF HELP. CENTERS ARE. THE
STATE SHE SOMETIMES THE ONLY
WAY PEOPLE GET INTO COURT AND
HAVE ACCESS TO IT SO I THINK
THAT'S A- IT'S A TOUGH
SUBSTITUTE AND THOSE WERE THOSE
CENTERS DO AN AMAZING JOB OF
HELPING PEOPLE TRYING TO
PREPARE THEM. SO JUDGE WARNING
THAT. WE KNOW THAT
UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS IN
FAMILY LAW IS STE THE SINGLE
BIGGEST. THAT THAT WE FIND THEM
DO YOU OR HOW DO YOU HANDLE IT
IF YOU HAVE ONE PARTY THIS
REPRESENTED ONE PARTY THAT'S
NOT REPRESENTED. WHAT DOES THE
COMMON COMPLAINT THAT WE GET
FROM ATTORNEYS IS THAT THEY
THINK THE JUDGES BEEN TOO MUCH
OF AN ADVOCATE OR TRYING TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD TOO
MUCH FOR THE PROPUBLICA. BUT
THERE ARE SOME PROCEDURAL. MINE
FIFTH PEOPLE OF THE PROPOSED.
WILL FALL INTO. I THINK I'M
ALSO CHARGED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MOVING THE
CASE ALONG. AND SO IT. ALTHOUGH
MY ATTORNEY ME PROTESTS LOUDLY
I WAS PROBABLY HELP THAT
PROPOSED IT AGAIN. THANKFULLY
NOW WE ALSO HAVE THE SELF HELP
CLINIC OR THE SELF HELP CENTER
IS THAT WE COOPER THEM
DOWNSTAIRS TO. HOW WHEN I SAY
DOES THIS NOT BUSINESS
DOWNSTAIRS RIGHT RIGHT. BUT
THEN. KIND OF CASE POINT. IN
SOME WAYS THEY NEED TO BE
ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS AND
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO AND THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW HOW TO
SO THAT'S KIND OF A TOUGH.
BUYING THAT. THE JUDGE OR IN
BECAUSE YOU ARE OBLIGATED TO
MOVE THE CASE ALONG. YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIND. A FAIR VENUE
BUT WHEN SOMEONE DOESN'T HAVE
AN ADVOCATE IN A SYSTEM THAT
EXPECTS THAT ADVOCATE. AND
SOMEONE DOES. THAT ALMOST
EXACERBATES THE IT DOES
EXACTLY. DOES THE TENSION. IS
THE TENSION BETWEEN WANTED TO
DO HELP. ONCE MOVE YOUR CASE
ALONG AND ETHICAL
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT YOU HAVE
TO BE MUTUAL OR TO BE PERCEIVED
TO BE NEUTRAL SO THAT THE OTHER
SIDE THAT IS REPRESENTED IN.
THE FIVE THOUSAND TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR RETAIN THE THINGS I PAY
FOR AN ATTORNEY AND THE JUDGE
IS HELPING THE OTHER THOUGHT.
EVER SYSTEM. IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT FAIRNESS AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY IN FAMILY LAW IN
PARTICULAR THE JUDGE IS NOT A
POTTED PLANT THE JUDGE IS MEANT
TO BE ACTIVE IN THE CASE
ESPECIALLY WHEN I HAVE CHILDREN
INVOLVED THE FACT THAT ONE
PARTY HAS REPRESENTATION
DOESN'T MEAN THAT I SHOULD
OVERLOOKED THE PROCEDURE
DEFICITS ON THE REPRESENTATIVE
JUST BECAUSE THE OTHER SIDE HAS
MANAGED TO GAIN A PROCEDURAL
BONTA. YEAH RIGHTS OF A SONG
LOADED QUESTION BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS
FOR A LONG TIME HOW DO WE GET A
TURN IN THE BAR TO PARTICIPATE
MORE IN FUNDING WILL. SO I THE
THAT WE'VE MAY. FAST IMPROVE.
THE MIX OF FUNDING FOR LEGAL
AID FROM THE STATE BAR IS
INTEREST ON I LAWYER TRUST
ACCOUNTS. WHICH THE STATE BAR
CERTIFIES FOR THEIR INTEREST
BASED ON A TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN LEGISLATIVE BILL.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY COMPATIBLE
INTEREST ALL THESE ACCOUNTS. OF
THAT THE OFFER TO OTHER
CUSTOMERS AND SO THE STATE BAR
HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVELY
NEGOTIATED WITH FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND WHAT YOU'VE
SEEN AS A FOR HOW PERCENT
INCREASE. AND I'LL TO
DISTRIBUTE. A TWENTY TWENTY
WILL BE JUST. IT'S A FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN AYE OLD TO
OF REVENUE- ALONE- FOR LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING-
THE JUSTICE GAP FUNDS THAT ARE
IN THE LICENSING FEES AND OTHER
DONATIONS. AND SO I THINK WE'VE
MADE AN INCREDIBLE OF. A
GAINES- FROM FOUR YEARS AGO
WHERE THE DISTRIBUTION WAS I
THINK ABOUT FORTY MILLION. TEN
AND WE KEEP TRYING TO. FOR
INSTANCE THE SPECIALLY SINCE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
BACKED OFF ON SOME OF ITS
OBLIGATIONS LEGAL SERVICES.
WE'VE BEEN FEELING THE
OBLIGATION O STEP UP I THINK
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO PARTICIPATE-
QUESTIONS OF THIS PANEL. THIS
JUST WHERE IT MAY BE JUST THE
GENERAL WHEN I AND I AND I'M
HEARING YOU. TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT OF I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU. WE ALWAYS HAVE A
DISAGREED GETTING THAT THE DATA
OF I DEAL. WITH A CONSTITUENCY
DOES MOSTLY IMMIGRANT- HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE FORMING
INCARCERATED THAT MAY NOT WANT
TO GO BACK TO COURT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES OR ANY REASON-
HAVE YOU LOOK AT. HOW DO YOU
GET. INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO MAY BE
REYES. OR WHETHER OR SYSTEM HAS
NOT ALWAYS FRIENDLYTO THEM BUT
THEY NEED. LEGAL AID THEY NEED
HELP AND THEY MAY NOT SHOW UP.
BECAUSE OF THOSE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE DO YOU TAKE THAT IN
CONSIDERATION AS TO HOW DO YOU.
YOU KNOW YOU TRY TO GET THIS
THIS MONEY IN BUT HOW DO YOU
REACH OUT IS THAT SOMETHING FOR
ANOTHER PANEL. TO KIND OF
DISCUSS. IF I MAY I THINK IT
CONNECTS TO MULTIPLE AREAS ONE
IS JUST HAVING THE INFORMATION
OF WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU GO TO
COURT WHAT HAPPENS- THE DATA
SHOWS THAT MORE PEOPLE MORE
PEOPLE ARE FEARFUL ABOUT. UP
ACTION ACTUALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO VETERANS ISSUES EMPLOYMENT
IN FAMILY LAW- I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S NECESSARILY THE GOVERNMENT
AS OPPOSED TO THE OPPOSING
PARTY AT TIMES. AND HOW THAT
MAY INFLUENCE WERE LOOKING INTO
THAT LITTLE BIT MORE- I THINK
IN TERMS OF- THE FEAR FACTOR.
THAT'S REAL A AND IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON. WHERE YOU'RE OUT
WHAT YOUR STATUS IS WHAT
LANGUAGE YOU SPEAK. TO FORMER
LEGALLY LAWYER AND WE WOULD GET
RIGHT ALL THE TIME TO COME TO
COURT WE'RE GONNA DEPART YOUR
CLIENT. ONE ON ONE AND THAT'S
THE OUT REACH THAT MANY LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATIONS DO AS WELL AS
A SELF HELP COURTS AND- THE-
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE WORKING WITH THESE CLIENTS.
A LOT OF LEGAL AID WORK WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE THOSE INDIVIDUAL
RELATIONSHIPS WORKING WITH-
BARBER POPULATIONS LIKE THE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULTS AND SO- I
THINK ALL THAT IS BASED ON
HAVING. ACCURATE INFORMATION.
BUILDING THAT TRUST AND-
SUPPORTING THOSE CLIENTS IN
THEIR OWN- PROBLEM AT THIS.
THEY RIGHT OTHER QUICK SO THE
SPELL ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK WE'VE MADE THE
CASE FOR THE THAT NEED HERE
PANEL TO IT'S GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT EXISTING PROGRAMS
TO HELP ON REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS WE HAVE FUNNY HUFF
PRINCIPLE MANAGING ATTORNEY
CENTER FOR FAMILIES CHILDREN
THE COURT. WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA AND BERNARDO
WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNTY TULARE COUNTY PUBLIC
LIFE LAW LIBRARY AND PRESIDENT
THE CALIFORNIA LIBRARY SERVICES
BOARD. WELCOME. YEAH OKAY LET'S
GO AHEAD AND CHECK THE CAR.
THIS IS SUCH A GREAT FOR FIVE
LOVE. SOMEHOW FIND. OKAY THANK
YOU. AT A GOOD MORNING I'M MORE
HOW FIVE HAD THE ONLY OF FOR
THE CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL FOR TWO
YEARS ON SELF HELP AND LEGAL
SERVICES ISSUES AND- IN THAT
TIME I'VE SEEN THE CUT COURT
BECOME PART OF THE CONTINUING
THE LEGAL SERVICES WHERE YOU
SEE. BETWEEN TEN AND SIXTEEN
I'M SORRY I GOT IDEA WAS
LOOKING I THINK BUT- LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING TO COURT.
BUT A HUGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
GET LEGAL ASSISTANCE NOW ARE
GETTING IT FROM COURT SELF HELP
CENTERS AND THAT'S A HUGE SHIFT
RIGHT IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
SO WE STARTED WITH- FAMILY LAW
WE START WITH THE FAMILY LOVE
FACILITATOR PROGRAM WHERE WE
HIRED EXPERIENCE TOURNEY'S TO
HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT PREPARE THE
PLEADINGS- UNDERSTAND. HOW TO
CAL STATE GUIDELINES AND
PREPARE FOR COURT AND THEN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE HECK
HAPPENED IN COURT. AND WHAT THE
EXPERTS DO NEXT A WEAPON STEPS
WERE. WE'VE IT THE WAS MORE
MISTER FOR THE PAY. AND IT WAS
ENORMOUSLY HEALTH FOR THE COURT.
THAT COURTS HAD THE- THAT THEY
NEEDED TO MAKE DECISIONS BASED
ON THE FACTS AND LAW. AND WHAT
WE FOUND IN FAMILY LAW IS THAT
MOST OF THE CASES BOTH SIDES
ARE AND REPRESENTED I THINK
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED THIS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING ISSUE
WITH UNBALANCED REPRESENTATION.
BUT TE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
CASES ARE AND REPRESENT. AND
SO- CURRENTLY AS WE SEE YOU
KNOW SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SEVENTY
FIVE AND 90% OF LITIGANTS IN
FAMILY LAW CASES ARE IDENTIFIED
AS NOT HAVING ATTORNEYS. BUT IN
REVIEWING CASE FILES IT IS VERY
CLEAR THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ASSISTANCE IF YOU'RE READING
THE PLEADINGS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE DOCUMENTS. THEY ARE THEY'RE
GETTING ASSISTANCE AND THEIR ME
THROUGH THEIR CASES BECAUSE FOR
MANY PEOPLE WHO JUST NEED SOME
HELP WITH THE PAPERWORK WITH
THE PAST. IF HELPING SOMEBODY
LISTEN TO THEM. MISSION OF
AUTHORITY WHO'S AT THE COURT
WHO CARES- AND SO THAT HAS MADE
A HUGE DIFFERENCE SO LET ME
GIVE YOU SEE OUR- WE'VE GOT NOW
FOR US SINCE THAT VERY SMALL
BEGINNING WE NOW THE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND NEARLY
A MILLION- CUSTOMER ENCOUNTERS
A PROVIDING ASSISTANCE. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS IMPORTANT
AND CRITICAL ABOUT CORPORATE
SELF HELP CENTERS IS WE NOT
JUST DEALING WITH THE LOWEST OF
LOW INCOME FOLKS WE ARE ABLE TO
SERVE PEOPLE AS A WHOLE IN
PLACE WE HAVE THIS HUGE
POPULATION OF MODEST MEET
PEOPLE WHO REALLY HAVE NO
ACCESS WITHOUT LIVE BAIT
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE MAKING THREE
TEN DOLLARS WEEK. TECH ELIGIBLE
FROM. NOW HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
HIRE AN ATTORNEY THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE AND NOW IS BEING ME.
OF SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
REAL BENEFITS OF HAVING MORE
SERVICES FOR CORPORATE SELF
HELP CENTER SEC- SO I'LL GIVE
AN EXAMPLE OF A OF A WOMAN WHO
COMES IN WHO NEEDS TO GET A
DIVORCE. AND SHE MAY BE MAKING.
FOUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN DOLLARS A
MONTH ON MY GOSH ARE FOUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN DOLLARS A WEEK
ON MY GOSH- AND- BUT THERE'S
NOT LEGAL AID HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE FAMILY LAW
ASSISTANCE IN MANY YEARS OR SHE
MAY BE OVER THAT. INCOME
LIMITATION. WHAT HAPPENS WHAT-
OPTIONS SHE COMES TO SELF HELP
SHE HEARD ABOUT IT FROM A
FRIEND OR FROM THE COURT OR
SOMEBODY SHE'LL COME IN IT
NORMALLY SHE'LL BE- IF IT'S A
SMALL COURTROOM PROBABLY BE
DOING WHEN WE WENT ON WHEN
ASSISTANCE IF IT'S A LARGER
COURT A LOT OF SHOPPING
WORKSHOPS SETTING AND PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE HE CONSERVE
NINE PEOPLE IN A WORKS SAID FOR
AND GIVE THEM THREE HOURS TO
EXPLANATION YOU'D ONLY BE TO
SERVE PEOPLE FOR TWENTY MINUTES
IF YOU WERE DOING ONE ON ONE.
SO YOU CAN ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
AND SHE CAN GET THE INFORMATION
SHE NEEDS AND THE CAMARADERIE
OF THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE SO IT ISN'T THAT SHE'S
GOING THROUGH THIS HERSELF
SHE'S PART OF IT UNITY SHE'LL
GET HER PAPERWORK DONE GEN THAT
IS SO THAT SHE CAN FILE WITH
THE COURT SAYING USING COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY AND SERVICES THOSE
PLEADING BUT JUST AS MUCH OF
REFER THE KIND OF. XIN ON. YOUR
SITE AND MARK TO BE A TO DO THE
MAN TO STARTED DISCLOSE. TO
YOUNG GO HOME AND FIND OUT OF
THE INCOME TOGETHER HER
SCHEDULE AND DEBTS ALL THAT
INFORMATION TOGETHER. NORMALLY
THAT'S A LITTLE CHALLENGING SO
PEOPLE COME BACK IN AND GET
OME MORE HELP- TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND AT THAT POINT. A
LOT OF TIMES THE CASE COULD BE
COMPLETED MANY MANY CASES GO BY
DEFAULT WHERE THE OTHER SIDE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY RESPOND AND
AS LONG AS THE INFORMATION IS
IN THE- IN. THE CASE CAN BE
FINISHED UP WITH THE PAPERWORK.
OTHER TIMES STILL HAVE AN
AGREEMENT. AND THAT AGAIN COULD
BE INCORPORATED INTO THOSE
FINAL PAPERS AND THEY CAN WALK
AWAY WITHOUT A JUDGMENT. FOR
THE OTHER PERSON MIGHT RESPOND
IT MIGHT HAVE COME TO THE SELF
HELP CENTER IN AND DECIDED THAT
WAS IN. THE OP THAT PERSON'S
BEST INTERESTS. AND SO THEN THE
COURT CAN- WORK ON SETTLEMENT
PROCEDURES WORK ON ASSISTANCE
FOR THE PERSON WITH TRIAL
WHATEVER IT IS. BUT THE GOAL
IS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK THAT HAS BEEN REALLY
HELPFUL WITH THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. IS BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE MORE SETTLEMENT
DISTANCE PEOPLE. MOST OBVIOUSLY
LIKE TO GET CASE DONE. THEY
WANT TO BE SPANKING COURT
SYSTEM FOR EVER COMING BACK
FROM WHERE I'M HEARINGS THAT
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO GET THINGS
DONE. BUT THANK YOU TO MAKE
SURE THAT IS. REASONABLE
APPROPRIATE. TO I'M ALONG IF
MANY TEMPER ORDERS FOR SUPPORT
FOR TEST FOR HIM FOR. ALL THIS
KINDS OF THINGS AND MAKING THAT
SUPPORT. SO WHETHER IT'S IN A
GROUP SETTING WHETHER IT'S ONE
ON ONE PEOPLE ARE MAKING THEIR
WAY THROUGH THESE DIVORCE
PROCEEDINGS. AND TRULY- GETTING
REAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE. AND THE
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION DATA IS
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH- WHERE
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY WERE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THEY KNOW WHAT THE NEXT
STEPS ARE AND THEY CAN PROCEED
WITH HER CASE- AND AS WE KNOW
FROM- THEY TESTED CCAP STEADY.
CUSTODY IS AN INCREDIBLY HIGH
OF CONCERN FOR PEOPLE. ALL THE
LEGAL PROBLEMS IT'S THE THING
THAT REALLY MOST AFFECTS THEIR
LIVES. SO IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
ASSISTANCE. AND BY HAVING THE
PERSON AT THE SELF HELP CENTER%
THEY CAN A HELP A PERSON FRAME
THE CASE AND RESOLVE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. BUT ALSO. BE THAT
PERSON SAID THAT THE JUDGE IS
ABLE TO NAY THE IF. AND MAKE
MORE OF A DECISION BASED ON THE
FACTS AND THE LAW RATHER THAN
ANY KIND PROCEDURAL PROBLEMS.
SO BUT THEN WE HAVE THE
LANDLORD TENANT SITUATION THE
SAME PERSON MAYBE BEING KICKED
OUT OF HER HOUSE RIGHT BECAUSE
SHE DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
IN IN SELF HELP NORMALLY WITH
TENANTS WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE PROVIDING THEM AN ANSWER
AND BUYING THEM SOMETIME AND-
SAID THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY POTENTIALLY TO TALK
THE LANDMARK BUT I WILL SAY
HAVING REVIEWED HUNDREDS OF
FILES- FOR THE DRIVER
EVALUATION- WE DO A GREAT JOB
WITH THE PAPERWORK BUT
NEGOTIATING OR GOING TO TRIAL
AGAINST AND EXPERIENCED- LAWYER
IS. INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT WITH
LITTLE OR IN TERMS OF HELPING
PEOPLE ON HELPING WITH. BUT I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SAY
IS THAT'S AN AREA AT THAT AT
THAT TRIAL LEVEL PET SETTLEMENT
LEVEL WHERE I DO THINK
REPRESENTATION IS REALLY
FUNDAMENTAL. BUT WHAT YOU'D SEE
IN SELF HELP IS THAT- THAT
PERSON MAY HAVE LET ANOTHER
PERSON STAY IN THE HOME TO BE
ABLE. I'M SURE ROOM IN ORDER TO
MAKE IT SAYS. I DON'T IF THAT
PERSON DOES PAY. THAT PERSON IS
CONSIDERED A LAMB OR- SHE'S TO
HAVE TO FILE AN EVICTION ACTION
TO GET THAT PERSON OUT IF SHE
HAD A HOME AND THAT- SHE
BROUGHT SOMEBODY IN EITHER TO
BE NICE. OR TO BE ABLE TO
PREVENT A FORECLOSURE. OF WERE
BEING ABLE CARE PROPERTY TAXES
SHE IS NOW WITH THE LANDLORD
AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN THE
STATE THAT IS PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE IN THOSE CASES TO
KEEP PEOPLE FROM LOSING THEIR
HOMES. THAN SELF HELP AND SO
AGAIN WE NEED THAT SORT OF
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES OF TO BE
ABLE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
IDENTIFY I WAS TWENTY YEARS
AGO. I WOULDN'T THAT LOWER
LIMITS. IT IS A HUGE POP. IN IN
FACT AND HELP. IN MANY COURTS
ABOUT HALF THE TO BE SIR. ARE
THOSE LANDLORDS. AND HALF OF
THEM ARE TENANTS. SO WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT SORT OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL UNFAIRNESS OF THE
ISSUES AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY- GET TAXES TO THE
COURT SYSTEM. AND I JUST REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THESE ISSUES
AND TO START THINKING ABOUT
THIS IN A SORT OF MODULAR WAY.
AND SINCE I HAVE TWENTY SECONDS
I'M JUST GOING TO SAY PART OF
THE THING IS WE'RE TRYING TO
LEARN BY DOING AGAIN YOU MAY BE
COMING IN. BUT YOU MAY BE
TALKING TO SOMEBODY ON SKYPE-
EITHER IN A WORKSHOP SETTING-
AT THE COURTHOUSE OR ON YOUR
OWN. LAPTOP FOR YOUR OWN PHONE-
WE ALSO HAVE A SELF HELP
WEBSITE WE HAVE SIX MILLION
PEOPLE A YEAR WHO USE THE SELF
HELP WEBSITE WITH STEP BY STEP
INFORMATION. IT'S FULLY
TRANSLATED INTO SPANISH. AND SO
FOR EXAMPLE THIS IS YOU KNOW IF
YOU WERE TRYING TO COLLECT OF.
A HOW TO RESPOND IF THE DEBT
COLLECTOR IS COMING AFTER YOU
AGAIN HOW DO YOU DO THAT AND IT
MAY INVOLVE NEGOTIATION BUT
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE. WE HAVE
A WEBSITE THAT SET UP FOR THE
SELF HELP PROFESSIONALS SO THAT
THEY CAN SHARE RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY'RE NOT
REINVENTING THE WAY ALL. AND
WITH A TRADING MATURE IT'S AN
SIMPLE INSTRUCTIONS. AND THEN
HAVE DEVELOPED A GUIDELINES FOR
OPERATION OF SELF HELP CENTERS
AND DEVELOP TOOLS. SO THE
COURTS CAN. IDENTIFY WHAT THEY
CAN DO BETTER AND HOW THEY CAN
IMPROVE. WE DID WE ARE ABLE
THEY DO TRAININGS- AND THAT IS
HE NOR MISLI HELPFUL BOTH IN
PERSON SO PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY
GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER AND
TALK. AND ALSO- ONLINE
TRAINING. AND WE HAVE A VERY
ACTIVE LISTENER OF. SO I REALLY
OUR- COMMAND THE COMMITTEE ON
ITS WORK HAD THE THOUGHTFULNESS
AND AGAIN URGE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THE CONTINUUM OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF LEGAL NEEDS.
THE REPRESENTATION IS KEY FOR
SOMETHING'S BUT MAY NOT BE
ACROSS NECESSARY FOR OTHERS
LEGAL ASSISTANCE AS NECESSARY.
BUT IT MAY NOT BE FULL
REPRESENTATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIS BERNARDO THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE
CHAIRWOMAN WEBER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY. YOUR COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES ARE THE PIONEERS OF
SELF HELP LEGAL SERVICES WE
SERVE ON THE FRONTLINE OF
ACCESS TO JUSTICE CREATED BY
ACT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
YEARS AGO COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
ARE PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND OUR
MISSION REMAINS THE SAME TODAY
TO PROVIDE FREE ACCESS TO LEGAL
SIR. MATERIALS TO ALL PERSONS
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES ARE OFTEN
THE BEST AND ONLY OPTION FOR
THOSE LOOKING FOR LEGAL
INFORMATION. AND TULARE COUNTY
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE USE
STARS LIBRARY SERVICES LAST
YEAR AND THAT NUMBER GROWS EACH
YEAR. EVERY DAY LAW LIBRARIES
HELP IN MATTERS OF JUSTICE
CUSTODY DISPUTES EVICTIONS
LEGAL FORMS BUT OUR BREAD AND
BUTTER ARE THE RANGE OF
QUESTIONS FROM PEOPLE. MANY
REFER ADDRESS FROM SELF HELP
CENTERS QUESTIONS ABOUT
EXPUNGEMENT PROPERTY HOW TO
START A BUSINESS IMMIGRATION
DISCRIMINATION ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS. BANKRUPTCY VETERANS
RIGHTS END OF LIFE PLANNING THE
LIST GOES ON. PEOPLE KNOW
LIBRARIES AS SAFE FRIENDLY
PLACES WHERE EVERYBODY CAN GO
FOR HELP COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
ARE THE CITY WERE ALL ABOUT
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE. WE HELP
EVERYONE LITIGANTS AND NON
LITIGANTS ALIKE NO LEGAL
SUBJECT OUTSIDE OUR SCOPE OF
SERVICE NO RESTRICTIONS BY
INCOME LEVEL. BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE NEVER HANDLED A
LEGAL MATTER ON THEIR OWN OUR
LIBRARIANS ARE TRAINED TO
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO THEIR
STORE. TO REACH THE LEGAL
QUESTION THEY NEED HELP WITH.
WE HOPE THE GRANDMOTHER ASKING
HOW TO TRANSFER HER HOME TO HER
GRANDKIDS THE NEW DEADLINE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW PAID FAMILY
LEAVE FORKS. AND WHEN THERE'S A
NATURAL DISASTER BUT LOCAL LAW
LIBRARIES HELP VICTIMS WITH THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT FEMALE
ASSISTANCE INSURANCE SMALL
BUSINESS FUNDING AND MORE. WE
ALSO REFER PEOPLE TO OTHER
AGENCIES WHO CAN ALSO HELP.
CALIFORNIA'S LAW BY PRES OVER
HALF OF MEAL MILLION PEOPLE IN
PERSON LAST YEAR. MOST
LIBRARIES KEEP LEGAL SELF HELP
BOOKS AND PRACTICE GUIDE IN
PRINT AND ITS PEOPLE HAVE GROWN
COMFORTABLE WITH TECHNOLOGY
LIBRARIES HAVE ADDED MORE
PUBLIC COMPUTERS AND FREE WIFI.
WE PROVIDE FREE ACCESS TO
EXPENSIVE ONLINE LEGAL
DATABASES LIKE WESTLAND LEXUS.
AND THE POPULAR PLAIN ENGLISH
SELF HELP BOOKS FROM NOLO
PRESS. SOME LIBRARIES HAVE
GROWN BEYOND THE FOUR WALLS TO
HAVE BRANCH LIBRARIES AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. OUR LIBRARY STAFF THE
STATE WIDE ASK A LAW LIBRARY
WHICH IS A FREE ONLINE SERVICE
PROVIDING. LIVE CHAT WITH A
LIBRARIAN. SOME LIBRARIES HAVE
BECOME VIBRANT ACTIVE LEGAL
EDUCATIONAL CENTERS WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE WILL TALK ABOUT IN
THE NEXT POUND. I DO WANT TO
DISPEL THREE MYTHS LAW
LIBRARIES ONE COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES ARE JUST FOR
ATTORNEYS FALLS. INTO LARRY
COUNTY OVER 80% OF THOSE WE
HELP IN OUR LIBRARY ARE NON
ATTORNEYS WITH THE GAP IN
ACCESS TO JUSTICE EVER WIDENING
ALL OUR LIBRARIES ARE SEEN MORE
MORE PEOPLE HAVING TO HANDLE
THEIR OWN LEGAL MATTERS. EVERY
MYTH TO EVERYTHING IS ON THE
INTERNET NO. LEGAL PRACTICE
GUIDES AND SAMPLE FORMS ARE
EXPENSIVE COPYRIGHTED MATERIAL
LEGAL PUBLISHERS DON'T GIVE
AWAY FOR FREE ON THE INTERNET.
BUT THEY'RE AVAILABLE IN OUR
LAW LIBRARIES AND ARE SKILLED
PROFESSIONALS CAN CONNECT
PEOPLE WITH RELIABLE ONLINE
RESOURCES AND PRACTICE GUIDES
TOGETHER. THE LIBRARIAN HELPS
PEOPLE GET ON AND STAY ON TRACK
ON MY DESK IS A COFFEE MUG FROM
THE LIBRARY OF CAL CONGRESS
THAT SAYS LIBRARIAN THE
REGIONAL SEARCH ENGINE. LAW
LIBRARIANS ARE THE FACE OF
LEGAL INFORMATION. MATH THREE
THE COUNTY LAW LIBRARY IS A
COUNTY DEPARTMENT NOT TRUE. THE
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY IS AN
pINDEPENDENT PUBLIC AGENCY
GOVERNED BY A LOCAL BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. UPWARDS OF 90% OF THE
LIE DEEP LIBRARIES FUNDING
COMES FROM A VERY SMALL PORTION
OF ITS SUPERIOR COURT CIVIL
FILING FEE. AND BECAUSE THE
LIBRARIES SO DEPENDENT ON PAID
FILING FEES THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE IS VERY BETWEEN
COUNTIES. IF THERE WERE
DEPENDABLE FUNDING FOR COUNTY
LAW LIBRARIES THEN THE SERVICES
I'VE TALKED BUT WOULD BECOME
AVAILABLE ACROSS COUNTIES. IN
CLOSING YOUR COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES ARE WORKING HARD TO
MEET THE CHANGING NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT SOMETHING'S
WILL ALWAYS STAY THE SAME LAW
LIBRARIES WILL ALWAYS BE A
PLACE WHERE EVERY PERSON IS
WELCOME. WITH THE FREEDOM TO
LEARN ABOUT ONCE LEGAL RIGHTS
WILL ALWAYS BE PROTECTED. AND
WHERE THE PURSUIT OF THE RULE
OF LAW WILL ALWAYS BE RESPECT.
IS AN HONOR FOR US TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SIR BECAUSE REALLY BACK NAY
BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT. YOU BOTH
DO IS ABOUT PROVIDING SELF HELP
RESOURCES. LOVE LIBRARIES ALSO
FOR ATTORNEYS FROM TIME TO TIME
BUT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT AND
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS. TALK
ABOUT THE COORDINATION BETWEEN
LAW LIBRARIES AND SELF HELP
CENTER'S BUT ALSO AMONG LAW
LIBRARIES SELF HELP CENTERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BECAUSE- AS I
GO AROUND AND TALK DIFFERENT
COUNTIES WE HAVE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF. FUNDING AND ABILITY
AND CAPABILITY REALLY BOTH OF
OUR LIBRARIES AND WITH. SELF
HELP CENTERS SO HOW DO WE
IMPROVE COORDINATION HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
CLEAR ABOUT THESE RESOURCES AND
MAKING THEM AVAILABLE ACROSS
THE BOARD. AND THAT'S REALLY
FOR EACH OF YOU. I THINK WE ALL
WANT TO DO THAT WE WANT TO
COURT DATE WE WANT TO WORK
CLOSER TOGETHER AND SOMETIMES
IT'S- MAYBE IT'S JUST. I THINK
IT STAFF TIME. HONESTLY AS I
READ THE RESPONSES FROM OUR-
FROM SELF HELP CENTER STAFF IT
WAS USUALLY OH MY GOD I'VE GOT
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE WAITING
OUT THE DOOR AND I WOULD LOVE
TO GO MEET AND DO MORE THINGS
BUT I AM OVERWHELMED I THINK
THAT WE DO HAVE WE CERTAINLY
HAVE SELF HELP CENTERS THAT ARE
CO OF IT EITHER- IN SANTA CRUZ.
THE SELF HELP SET A LAW LIBRARY
I IS ALSO PART OF THE SELF HELP
CENTER AND NEVADA COUNTY THEY
KIND OF MERGED AND THEIR
CORRUGATED THERE'S A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH REFERRALS AND
PARTICULARLY. FOR CASES WHERE
SOMEBODY DOES NEED TO DO AS
WERE MOVING MORE INTO CIVIL
CASES I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
MORE IMPORTANT AS PEOPLE HAVE
TO DO MORE RESEARCH IN FAMILY
LAW WE HAVE DONE OUR BEST TO
GET THINGS ON FORMS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WRITE A LOT OF. MOTIONS
OUR POINTS AND AUTHORITIES OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT F YOU CAN
GET IT NOW BUT IN THE FORM
YOU'RE GOING TO BE OKAY AND
HONESTLY WE HAVE TO DEPEND ON
OUR WONDERFUL JUDGES TO HELP
MOVE SOME OF THOSE CASES
THROUGH BUT FIRST OF ALL I
THINK THAT BECOMES MUCH MORE
INJURED. BUT THERE IS A WE
SLEEP WITH TWO LOT MORE
COORDINATION BUT I THINK IN
MANY MANY COUNTIES ARE OUT OUR
VERY STRONG TOPICS AND THE WHEN
IT COMES TO MIND AND LA. LAWLER
HAS MORE SPACE THE SELF
CENTERED AND THEY HAVE WORK TO
DO TUNES WHERE THEY CAN HAVE
SOME OF THE SERVICES FOLLOW
BRADY BUTLER BREAK OPEN FOR
HOURS AFTER THE COURT CAN IN.
SOME SITUATIONS. WE WILL WELL
THE COURT NATION AND THE CO.
WITH THE COLLEAGUE IN SELF HELP.
AND THE AND OTHER IN THE BONO
SERVICE. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR TO
BILL THOSE CLOSE. IT AND I
THINK THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE I
HAVE HAD. BOTH GROUPS COME AND
TALK TO ME AND IN REALLY YOUR
IN THE SAME BUSINESS AND SO
FIGURING OUT. HOW RECORDED HOW
WE LEVERAGE AND DISTINGUISH
WHERE APPROPRIATE BUT WORK
TOGETHER ON THE BROADER SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT FOR A REPRESENT
LITIGANTS IS. REALLY KEY YEAH I
WILL SAY BACK IN THE DAY WHEN
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
READY FOR THE COURT BUDGET WE
USED TO HAVE REGULAR TO-
COORDINATION MEETINGS WITH
TEAMS- FROM THE SELF HELP
CENTER FROM THE LAW LIBRARY THE
SMALL CLAIMS ADVISOR. AND A
JUDICIAL OFFICER IN COURT
ADMINISTRATOR TO WORK ON THOSE-
LOCAL PLANS AND COORDINATION.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS ONE
THING THAT UNFORTUNATELY SORT
OF WENT AWAY WITH- THE
RECESSION BUT- THOSE KINDS OF
SERVICES ARE GREAT I WOULD SAY
THE MAJOR DISTINGUISHING
FEATURE BETWEEN THE LAW
LIBRARIES AND SELF HELP. IS IT
IN SELF HELP FOR THE MOST PART
WE'RE HELPING PEOPLE GET THEIR
FORM STAND AND IT OFFICE FOR
PROCESSING THINGS AND CLEARLY-
THE LAW LIBRARIANS ARE ALSO YOU
DON'T DIRECTING PEOPLE IN MANY
WAYS AND- HELPING THEM WITH
RESOURCES. BUT MUCH OF THE
FOCUS IN SELF HELP AREAS WORK
ON AT WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU
READY TO GO TO COURT- OR HELP
YOU YOUR STAND WITH YOUR YOUR
NECK STEPS ARE OR WHAT I. IT
MAY NOT SENSE A FREE. I
DEPENDING ON YOUR SITUATION SO
I THINK HAVE MADE HER STE
DISTINGUISH FACT. IN SMALL.
PARTICULARLY IN THE WORLD. THE
SELF HOW CENTER IS OFF THE- A
TURN AND WE CAN DON'T HAVE IT
LAWLER. SOME SOME OF THE SMALL.
AND SO THEIR HAND. EVERYTHING
THEY TO. DO IMMIGRATION
BANKRUPTCY KIND OF WHATEVER
COMES IN THE DOOR AND TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME BASIC ASSISTANCE
SERVE OUR COUNTRY LAWYER- KIND
OF MODEL. BUT AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU. SEE AN ART COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES IS THAT WE GO BEYOND
AND WE HAVE LONG FOR A LONG
TIME ON BEYOND. BASIC CIVIL AND
UP FAMILY LAW- TOPICS WE'VE
GONE BEYOND INTO THE FEDERAL
AND WE HAVE TO DO THAT MINISTRY
THEY HAVE. AGENCY HEARINGS.
COVER PROBATE. BUT MATTERS THAT
ARE OUTSIDE OF WHAT SELF HELP
CENTERS ARE DOING. TRUE OKAY
QUESTIONS FROM. THE DEATH SO
WAS WHAT. YES ARE WELL THANK
THANK OF YOU FOR YOU FOR YOUR
AND GIVING US THE SAME FROM THE
SIDE I'M TRYING TO THINK OF
THEM HOW FAR ARE WE AWAY FROM
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. ON SELF
HELP- WE'RE NOT THAT FAR OR
MAYBE FORTY FIVE MILLION AWAY-
IF WE CONTINUE THIS NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS. THE PARTS
IDENTIFIED IN NEED OF ABOUT
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS- TWO
YEARS AGO. OUR I WILL SAY AS WE
MOVE INTO CIVIL. I THINK THAT
MAY BE A LITTLE ONSERVATIVE. I
THINK AS WE START DOING MORE
CIVIL CASES- IT IS IT'S MORE
COMPLEX WE HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH
ALL THE WORK WE'VE DONE IN
FAMILY LAW- TRY TO MAKE THINGS
EASIER. BUT I DON'T THINK
WITHOUT PARK. AND BUT IN AND IT
AGAIN THE THING THAT'S GREAT IS
THEN WE CAN PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
A REALLY RELATIVELY LOW COST.
AND IDENTIFY THOSE CASES THAT
REALLY NEED LIKE LATE. ARE THEY
REALLY NEED A PRO BONO OR THEY
REALLY NEED- A PRIVATE ATTORNEY
AND THAT'S A KIND OF COURSEONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS ITSELF
HELPED AS ISRAELI SAYS. I THINK
I KNOW THAT YOU THIS IS EASY
IF- LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THE
ISSUES IN THE IN YOUR CASE THAT
WILL MAKE THIS DIFFICULT AND-
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND YOU
SOME. OTHER OTHER ASSISTANCE.
CAN YOU ALL LIBRARY WE A- IT
IDENTIFIED OF THE AMOUNT WE'VE
LOST SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
AND THAT'S A SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION THAT WILL BRING US BACK
TO OUR TWO THOUSAND NINE LEVEL
WHEN YOU IN THE FORM CIVIL
FEES. UNIFORM CIVIL FEE ACT WAS
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. OKAY I S. I
SIMPLY ASK THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY
TIME I GO INTO A MEETING PEOPLE
OF ALWAYS TELL ME WHERE WOULD
NOT- THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT I
DON'T AND I AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT BUT I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT.
FIRST OTHER PEOPLE SAY AND THIS
IS WHAT WE NEED TO GET TO WHERE
WE REALLY SHOULD BE WHAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE KIND OF
ACCESS THAT WE THINK IS
NECESSARY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STAFF AND- BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
I'M CONSTANTLY PIECING TOGETHER
STUFF WITH ITS THERE'S A
WHETHER IT'S A WOMEN TALKING
ABOUT SHOP HERE IN. PRESCHOOLS
AND YOU KNOW ALL THAT AND I'M
I'M CURRENTLY AS OF COURSE OKAY.
I GIVEN AND PEOPLE TELL ME
THEY'RE STILL BIG HOLE- I'M NOT
SURE IF I'M CONTRIBUTING TO THE
WHOLE OR WHAT I'M TELLING THE
WHOLE SO. I NEED TO KNOW WHAT
THE WHOLE LOOKS LIKE- SO I CAN
HAVE SOME IDEA AS WELL AS- AS
WHAT WHAT THE CONFERENCE OF
SERVICE WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR THE
PEOPLE. SO THERE IS A GREATER
SENSE OF ENGAGEMENT IN. AN
INFORMATION AND THAT WE FEEL
GOOD ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING. I
THINK EVERYONE FEELS GOOD THAT
THEY'RE DOING THE BEST THEY CAN
DO- BUT PROBABLYNOT THE BEST
THIS NECESSARY. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE ONGOING CHALLENGE.
YEAH AND I THINK THE OTHER
THING IS AN ACT WE HAVE BOTH OF
US BUT CERTAINLY- ON THE COURT
SIDE WE HAVE REALLY ALSO REALLY
TRY TO WORK WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
I THINK THAT. HAS MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE RIGHT. BEING ABLE
FILL OUT FORMS ONLINE. SO THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
REPETITIVE TYPING AND THE
INFORMATION GET SAVE FROM HER.
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT TIME
SEPARATE THE SELF HELP CENTER.
HAS MADE ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE WORLD. IT USED TO TAKE
VOLUNTEER SOMEONE OF OUR
PROGRAMS. OUR STUDIO A
CONSERVATORSHIP BUT WITH ONE OF
THE PROGRAM SO WE DEVELOPED.
NOW FIFTEEN MINUTES. RIGHT SO
YOU CAN SAY THAT TIME AND
ACTUALLY EXPLAIN THE PROCESS.
AND ACTUALLY LISTEN TO
SOMEBODY. SO THOSE KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL. FOR MAKING.
DIFFERENCE HOW MORE IN. ON LINE.
HE HE TO RAISE. PHONE UP. SO
THAT. WAY COMING. A REAL FOCUS
STERN. IS MY- A DIFFERENCE.
IT'D CHANGE I. A LOT TRACK PILE
TO DO. WE HAD ABOUT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE. USE LIVE TRACT-
IN A VERY SHORT I THINK WITH
THIS NINE WEEK PERIOD AND- THEY
WERE THRILLED WITH THE ANSWERS.
WE WERE STARVING ABOUT SEVEN
PEOPLE IN OUR- WITH NO
PUBLICITY. IT WAS JUST OFF FROM
THE SELF HELP WEBSITE I HAD NO
IDEA RIGHT THAT THERE WAS THAT
MUCH NEED FOR. NAME CHANGE A
PART OF ITS REAL ID PART OF ITS
IMMIGRATION THERE A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS. BUT I THINK THAT
COMBINATION. OF USING THE
TECHNOLOGY. AND THEN BEING
THERE FOR THOSE PEPLE WHO ARE
JUST NOT BEEN ABLE TO USE
TECHNOLOGY. THE PEOPLE WHO COME
TO THE COURT AND- WATSONVILLE.
WHO'VE NEVER BEEN IN AN
ELEVATOR BEFORE. IN ALL. OF
THEM. THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
HOPPING ON THEIR MOBILE PHONES-
TO WIN A LOT OF LEGAL TECH WORK
RIGHT SO WE NEED TO HAVE
PEOPLE. WHO CAN DO THAT. AND
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO IF I'M IN
THE MIDDLE FOR PROBATE
SITUATION I'M DEALING WITH THE
DEATH OF A LOVED ONE. IT IS NOT
A GREAT TIME TO BE LEARNING HOW
TO USE TECHNOLOGY AND- TO MY
LEGAL WORK SO YOU. SO IT'S THAT
COMBINATION OF BOTH. RIGHT THAT
MAKES THE MOST EFFECTIVE. THANK
YOU. BUT THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
DIE. RIGHT SIGNAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU FOR
MUCH A WE GO TO OUR- EARTH
PANEL INNOVATIVE PRO. AND
ANSWERS TO WHAT MORE WE CAN TO
A ACT TO JOE. WE HAVE LOUIS THE
DIRECTOR. OF THE- ASSISTING
COURT CUSTOMERS WITH EDUCATION
AND SELF HELP SERVICES ACCESS.
CENTER IN OF THE SENSES BECAUSE
PER COURT WE HAVE CENTRAL LEVIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY. CHARLENE
DEPTH- DIRECTOR CENTER FOR
FAMILIES CHILDREN IN COURTS OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND JUDGE
KEVIN BRAZIL WHO'S PRESIDING
JUDGE IN. LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
SO FOR THIS PANEL. BRING US ON
HOME WRAP IT UP. WHAT THAT'S
THE INNOVATION HOW DO WE SOLVE
OUR PROBLEMS WE'LL GET IT DONE
BY THE AFTERNOON RIGHT. SO MS
LEWIS. GOOD MORNING THINK
MORNING WELCOME THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. I WAS PRACTICING MY
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING ON MY
COMMUTE FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
REALIZE THAT THE HEAD OF. OUR
IN FORTY FIVE MINUTES HAD NEED
OF WHITTLED DOWN TO FIVE
MINUTES. SO THIS MORNING I GAVE
MS. CHRISTIANSEN A COPY OF MY
NOTES SO HOPEFULLY THE
COMMITTEE HAS RECEIVED COPIES
OF THAT SO THAT YOU CAN FOLLOW
ALONG AS WELL AS- I'M JUST
GOING TO SKIP OVER SOME OF THE
DETAILS SO THAT I CAN GET
STRAIGHT TO. THE IMPORTANT-
MESSAGE THAT I WANT TO PROVIDE
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND BASICALLY
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
INNOVATIONS IN THE BEST
PRACTICES IN SAN FRANCISCO. THE
ACT TO CENTER THE OF THE SELF
HELP CENTER INSECTS SUPERIOR
COURT. AND I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE GAPS IN SERVICE
AND UNMET NEEDS THAT ARE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS ARE
FACING. I JUST WANNA GIVE YOU
OVERVIEW OF THE AXIS IN SAN. IN
TWO. WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
RECEIVE PILOT FUNDING. TO
EXPAND OUR SELF HELP CENTER TO.
EXPAND SERVICES BEYOND THE
FAMILY LAW FACILITATOR SERVICES
BEYOND. SMALL CLAIMS AND WITH
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND WHEN OUR
DOORS OPEN IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. AND SEVENTEEN YEARS
LATER PRETTY MUCH TO THE TO A
MONTH OFF. WE ARE- KNOWN IN
I'VE BEEN TOLD WE ARE THE
CADILLAC OF THE SELF HELP IN
IN. THE STATE THAT DOESN'T
REALLY NECESSARILY MEAN WERE
BETTER THAN OTHER COUNTIES IT
MEANS THAT. WE HAD A JUMP START
AHEAD OF EVERYONE ELSE. WE
RECEIVED. FUNDING FROM MULTI
LEGAL SELF HELP CENTER. THE
DIVERSITY IN SAN FRANCISCO-
REQUIRED THAT WE MEET THAT BI
LINGUAL NEEDS OF THE- OF THE
POPULATION AND SO MOST OF OUR
MATERIALS. THAT OUR TRANSLATOR
ARE IN. OTHERS ENGLISH IS CHINA
SPANISH RUSSIAN VIETNAMESE. AND
TAGALOG. OUR RECRUITMENT OF
STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS- IT
PRIORITIZES BILINGUAL MULTI
LINGUAL- INDIVIDUAL SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY. LEVERAGE OUR
RESOURCES TO THE COMMUNITY. SO
WITH HIS HEAD IN THE JUMPS WE
WERE ABLE TO- HAVE A LOT OF
GROWING PAINS CHIU. A DID.
METHODS OF SERVER DELIVERY. AS
WELL AS I'M COME BACK AROUND
AND REVISITING METHODS THAT
WORKED BEFORE IT DIDN'T WORK
AND A REVAMP IT TO IMPROVE OUR
SERVICES AND INCREASE OUR
NUMBERS. TO MAXIMIZE HOW WE CAN
HELP THE PUBLIC. THEN WITH THAT
IN MIND- WE DEVOTE ACCESS
CENTER THAT WE HAVE TODAY I
WANT TO JUST GIVE YOU A
SNAPSHOT PICTURE. WE ARE HOUSE
IN THE COURTHOUSE AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF REAL ESTATE IN THE
COURTHOUSE BECAUSE OUR COURT
WERE UNDERSTANDS COURT
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THAT
WE NEED A LOT OF SPACE AND
FACILITIES FOR THE PEOPLE
COMING THROUGH OUR DOORS. OF
OUR MODEL IS- NOT WANT IF SMALL
SELF HELP IS NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL IF YOU BUILD IT THEY
COME AND WE TRY TO HAVE A- ONE
STOP SHOP APPROACH MEANING WE
DON'T WANT TO REFER FOLKS OUT
IF WE CAN HELP THEM. WITH OUR
SERVICES HOWEVER IF LEGAL
SERVICES OR OTHER AGENCIES
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO THAT PERSON OFFICIALS
CASE TYPE IT'S BETTER TO. TO
REFER FOLKS OUT TO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND WHO CAN GIVE MORE
SUPPORT TO THAT INDIVIDUAL. SO
WITH THE ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT
ALL WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS- WITH
THE FAMILY LAW FACILITATOR IN
SMALL CLAIMS THERE'S MUCH MORE
CASE TYPES THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT ARE NEEDED BY THE PUBLIC
SO. ARE IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
NOTES ARE OUR MENU OF SERVICES
HAVE BEEN OR HAVE AN EXPANSION
OF ALL AREAS OF FAMILY LAW
INCLUDING. SAME SEX MARRIAGES
WITH. CAN FOR PARENTAGE.
INSTEAD PARENT ADOPTIONS AND
THAT BASICALLY THE SAME SEX
MARRIAGES WHERE THE CHILD IS
BORN DURING THE MARRIAGE THE
PARENTS. WHICH LET'S SAY FOR
EXAMPLE TWO MOTHERS THE BIRTH
MOTHER AND THE OTHER MOTHER ARE
ON THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE. THEY
ARE THE PARENTS OF THIS CHILD
BUT- OF RECOGNITION OF THE
LEGAL STATUS IN THE
RELATIONSHIP THE CHILD. MAY BE
AT AN ISSUES SO THE NEXT STEP
IS TO HAVE AN ADOPTION DECREE
TO CONFIRM THAT THE PARENTAGE
OF THAT. UP FOR THAT CHILD SO
THOSE TYPE OF SERVICES ARE THE
EXPANSION OF FAMILY LAW NOT
JUST YOUR YOUR YOUR BREAD AND
BUTTER FAMILY LOG OUT DIVORCES
CUTS YOU VISITATION WEEK WE
HAVE TRIED TO EXPAND. THOSE
SERVICES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
WHAT'S COMING THROUGH OUR DOORS
WHAT THE COMMUNITY NEEDS AND
SAN FRANCISCO. WE PROVIDE A
NAME AND GENDER CHANGES WE
PROVIDE. OUT SMALL CLAIMS
ASSISTANCE AND RESIDENTIAL.
UNLAWFUL DETAINER STARTED CHIP
BUT THE PERSON CONSERVATIVE
SHIP OF THE PERSON MANY OF OUR
MENU OF SERVICES ARE VERY BROAD
SO THAT'S JUST THE MENU BUT WE
DIG DEEPER HOW DO WE GET A CAN.
HOW TO SET ASIDE A STIPULATION
HOW TO SET ASIDE EL OF A
JUDGMENT WHERE THE PARTY WAS
INCARCERATED OR WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL OR JUST WASN'T ABLE TO
MAKE IT TO COPY THE COURT
PROCEEDING OR TO ANSWER THEIR
THEIR THEIR- LEGAL MATTER. SO
OUR MENU IS PRETTY VAST AND
QUITE BROAD AND HAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT ABOUT I DO ONE
ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT WAS
WHO WAS ONLY ONE MAN ON MY
GOODNESS SO OUR WISH LIST OUR
WISH LIST IS- IF YOU LOOK AT
THE LAST PAGE OF THE GET THE
GAPS OUR WISH LIST IS THAT WE
CAN DO MORE SMALL CLAIMS
COLLECTION EXPANDING MEDIATION
FOR. FOR CALENDARS AND EVERY
SMALL CLIP WE HAVE NINETEEN
CALENDARS AND IN SAN FRANCISCO
ONLY A FEW CALENDARS ARE MET BY
OUR COLLABORATIONS WITH THE LAW
SCHOOLS SO WE LEVERAGE OF
RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY LAW
SCHOOL CLINICS WITH MEDIATION.
COMPONENTS IN OUR SMALL. WE OUR-
OF OUR LEGAL SIR. WE HOUSE TO
CONTRACT ATTORNEY IN THE COURT
HOUSE THE SHARK SARGENT SHRIVER
PROGRAM HAS A SELF HELP
COMPONENT WE HAVE THAT ATTORNEY
ON SITE SO THAT IS A SEAMLESS
TRIAGE. SEAMLESS REFERRAL OF
THE SERVICES WE DON'T HAVE TO
REFER SOMEONE TO GO INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO GET THAT SERVICE.
WE MAKE THE APPOINTMENT FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL AND BRING THAT
PERSON TO THE SELF. SELF HELP
PORTION OF OUR OFFICES WHERE
THE LEGAL AID I HOUSE IN ON
SITE WE ALSO HAVE OTHER
PROGRAMS WHERE. A WE HAVE
SATELLITE OFFICES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT SUCH CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES HOUSE IN THE
COURTHOUSE. RIGHT ACROSS FROM
OUR CHILD SUPPORT COURT. COURT
ROOM. WE UP GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY REGULARLY TO CHECK
OUT REACHED FOR SATELLITE- OUT
REACH IN THE IN CHINATOWN WHERE
SOME FOLKS MAY NOT WANT TO COME
TO. THE COURTHOUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID TO COME THROUGH THE
METAL DETECTOR THEY DON'T TRUST
GOVERNMENT. A WE GO INTO THE
COMMUNITY WE MAKE-
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
LEADERS SO THAT WE CAN- BE
INVITED INTO THEIR- THEIR
COMMUNITY FAIRS HAVE
INFORMATIONAL BOOTHS. BE
RECOGNIZED IN THE COMMUNITY
BEFORE PEOPLE WANT TO TALK TO
US ABOUT THE FORCE OR- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OR OTHER ISSUES THAT
THEY DON'T WANT- TO BE OUT.
KNOWN IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY HAVE THESE PERSONAL
ISSUES. SO WHEN WE GO INTO THE
KITCHEN WHERE THE SPANISH.
COMMUNITY TO DO THAT SAME TYPE
OUT REGION SO OUR
COLLABORATIONS WITH SINCE WE
ARE SO RICH IN. SAN FRANCISCO
WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S LAW
SCHOOLS IN. A LEGAL SERVICES
EVEN WITH ALL OF THAT WE HAVE
UNMET NEEDS IN OUR WISH LIST IS
ON THE ON MY LAST PAGE BUT-
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE TO DO. AND
JUST- REALLY REALLY QUICKLY IS
THAT THE DIFFERENCE WITH SMALL-
OF SELF HELP HELLO LIBRARY
SOMEONE SAYS I WANTED. CHANGE
MY CHILD'S NAY. AT LAWLER YOU
MAY IT RESOURCES WERE THE
STATURE WHAT OF FORMS THIS IS
YOU CHANGE CHILD NAME WITH THE
LAW. IS THE SELF HELP BETTER
AFTER. TREE I ING AND FINDING
OUT. LEGAL OPTION. AND. WHERE'S
THE OTHER PRINT TO BOTH PARTIES
AGREE. WE OFTEN. THAT THE NAME
CHANGE THE CHILD IS NOW REALLY
THE- OF VISIT IT'S A- TO JACK.
THIS IS THE NAME OF THE CHILD.
TO THE IS NOT THE FATHER. THIS
IS NOT THE FATHER I WANTED THE
NAME THE CHILD. SHE THE NAME
THE OTHER PAIR. THAT BECOMES A
HOLD TO BALL OF SETTING. A
PARENTAGE OF DICK OR J. OR
POPPED. AT THE HIGH. SO THE
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS TO TRIAGE
AND REALLY THAT IN GET TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CUSTOMER
WANTS FROM THEIR VISIT AT THE-
SELF HELP CENTER AND IT MAY NOT
BE THE FIRST OR SECOND. TRIAGE
PERSON THAT THEY SEE AT THE AT
THE COURT BECAUSE THERE'S
DIFFERENT PEOPLE SURROUNDING
THAT IS A ONE ON ONE. WITH THE
FACED WITH ONE OF MY WORKERS
NOW THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE TO
DISCLOSE THAT. THE REALLY HERE
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO CHANGE
PARENTAGE OF THEIR CHILD. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FOR HAVING ME
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEVEN GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. I WISH WE HAD TIME
FOR A SESSION OF TRUE PATRONS
STORIES. YOU KNOW THE ARTIST
WHO LEARNED ALL ABOUT
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY LAW AND-
AT HER LAW LIBRARY AND STARTED
HER OWN BUSINESS. THE HOMELESS
MAN WHO PURSUED HIS RATE OF MAN
DAVIS FOR OVER A YEAR TO
FINALLY WIN BACK. HIS SECTION
EIGHT CERTIFICATE AND GET
HOUSING. THE SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS WHO WON HER CASE
AGAINST A MAJOR. FOR AN AIRLINE
CARRIER BECAUSE HER LAW LIBRARY
HELP HER FIND THE OBSCURE
INTERNATIONAL TREATY THAT
ESTABLISHED JURISDICTION. IN
THE UNITED STATES. THE VICTIM
OF VIOLENT ABUSE IN HIS HOME
COUNTRY WHO WAS GRANTED ASYLUM
AFTER DRAFTING. AND ASYLUM
PETITION WITH THE HELP HE GOT
AT HIS LAW LIBRARY. AND I COULD
GO ON AND ON. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THERE'S NO PLACE
ELSE THESE PATRONS COULD HAVE
GOTTEN HELP WITH THEIR LEGAL
ISSUE. THERE WAS NO FORM OR
ONLINE RESOURCE THAT COULD HAVE
HELPED THEM. AND THERE ARE
MILLIONS MORE LIKE THEM. AND
THAT'S WHY COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
ARE DEVELOPING ALL KINDS OF NEW
AND INNOVATIVE COLLABORATIONS.
TO EFFICIENTLY EXPAND THE SCOPE
AND REACH OF OUR SERVICES. FOR
EXAMPLE MANY OF US INVITE LEGAL
AID AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE THEIR CLOTHES. AT OUR
LOW. THIS PROVIDES A DAMAGE TO
EVERY. FOR LEGAL A THEY CAN
FOCUS ALL THE RESOURCES UNDER
CLAIM. THIS. WE BILLS PROMOTION
REGISTRY AND ALL THE INDUSTRY
IF. FOR THE LONG. WE GET TO
PROVIDE BETTER. TO OUR PAY. AND
MORE PEOPLE COMING THE LIGHT.
BUT MùT IMPORTANT. FOR THE
PATRON. THEY GET ON GOING
ASSISTANCE. LEGAL ISSUE DON'T
COME WANTED IT. A PATRON MAY
ATTENDED. FOR A CONSERVE. OF A
LOVED ONE A RECORD EXPUNGEMENT
SO THEY CAN GET BACK TO WORK.
BUT IT A LAW LIBRARY THEY CAN
ALSO GET HELP WITH EVERY OTHER
LEGAL ISSUE THEY HAVE. MAYBE
THEY HAVE DEBT THAT'S PILING UP
BECAUSE OF THE BURDEN OF CARING
FOR THAT LEFT ONE. OR THEY NEED
TO DEAL WITH AN OLD TRAFFIC
CITATION THAT WENT TO WARRANT
SO THEY ACTUALLY CAN GET BACK
TO WORK. THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
WHEN THE CLINIC IS AT CITY HALL
OR A PUBLIC LIBRARY OR EVEN IN
A COURTHOUSE OR ANYWHERE ELSE
OTHER THAN YOUR COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY. I'M MANY OF US ALSO
SEND OUR STAFF TO. LEGAL
REFERENCE ASSISTANCE OR OFFER
CLASSES ON LEGAL TOPICS IN
PUBLIC LIBRARIES ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL OR REMOTE AREAS. BECAUSE
PUBLIC LAW LIBRARY PATRONS HAVE
LEGAL QUESTIONS BUT PUBLIC
LIBRARIANS DON'T HAVE LEGAL
EXPERTISE. THEY NEED OUR HELP.
WERE ALSO COLLABORATING WITH
SELF HELP CENTER TO NEW WAYS
LIKE ALLOWING THEM TO HOLD
PROGRAMS IN LAW LIBRARY SPACE
THIS ALLOWS THE PROGRAMMING TO
HAPPEN WHEN WORKING PEOPLE CAN
ATTEND AND WITHOUT THE
INTIMIDATION FACTOR OF GOING
INTO A COURTHOUSE LIKE THE
LEGAL AID COLLABORATIONS IT
ALSO PROVIDES THE CLIENTS. WITH
AN ONGOING RESOURCE FOR EVERY
OTHER OUT OF SCOPE ISSUE THEY
MIGHT HAVE. A COUPLE OF WELL
LIBRARIES HAVE EVEN STARTED
HAVING A CIVIL ATTORNEY OR MANY
CIVIL SELF HELP CENTER IN THE
LIBRARY. THIS REQUIRES
ESPECIALLY CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE COURT'S SELF HELP
CENTER TO AVOID OVERLAP IN
SERVICES BUT IT FILLS IN GAPS
IN COVERAGE IN A VERY
MEANINGFUL WAY. LANGUAGE ACCESS
IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE MORE
COULD BE DONE IF WE HAD
ADEQUATE FUNDING. SOME OF US
USED ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVE TO CONDUCT PILOT
PROGRAMS WITH TRANSLATION
SERVICES SO THAT REFERENCE
ASSISTANCE COULD BE PROVIDED IN
ANY OF A HUNDRED DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES. INCLUDING AMERICAN
SIGN LANGUAGE WE'RE ALSO
DEVELOPING MORE AND MORE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LAWYERS
LAWYERS IN LIBRARY PROVIDES
FREE SHORT CONSULTATIONS WITH
THE VOLUNTEER ATTORNEY TO
HEALTH HELP SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS OR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE TING COURT. FIGURE OUT IF
THEY'RE ON THE RIGHTTRACK AND
WHAT THEIR NEXT STEP SHOULD BE
ONE COMMENT WE GET REPEATEDLY
FROM PATRONS ABOUT LAWYERS IN
LIBRARY IS. NOW I HAVE HOPE.
SOME DAY EVERY COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY SHOULD HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO HOLD THESE
PROGRAMS. SOME OF US ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN LEGAL INCUBATORS
DESIGNED TO TRAIN NEWER
ATTORNEYS HOW TO DEVELOP A LAW
PRACTICE REPRESENTING MODEST
MEANS CLIENTS WE HELP TRAIN AND
KEEP THE COSTS LOW FOR
ATTORNEYS WHO WANT TO KEEP
THEIR RATES LOW. SOME OF US
PARTICIPATE IN REGIONAL EFFORTS
AND JOINT TASK FORCES REGARDING
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS ARE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
DISSEMINATES PRINT INFORMATION
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE DISASTERS
HAVE HIT. AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE COMMISSION ABOUT A
POSSIBLE STATE WIDE
COLLABORATION TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE TO
THE PUBLIC. FINALLY WE
COLLABORATE WITH EACH OTHER.
OUR NEWEST PROJECT IS VERY
EXCITING TO US USING ONE TIME
FUNDING WE'RE DEVELOPING A
STATEWIDE DATABASE OF FORMS AND
INSTRUCTION PACKETS. UNLIKE
COMMERCIALLY PRODUCED DATABASE
WHICH WE AREN'T ALLOWED TO
SHARE REMOTELY WE CAN SHARE OUR
OWN FORM PACKETS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL GUIDES AND ID BE
WONDERFUL TO ADD SELF HELP
CENTER PACKETS TO THAT LIST.
ALL OF THESE NEW COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS HELP EXPAND SERVICES IN
ACCESS REDUCE COURT COSTS
IMPROVE OUTCOMES. AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE MOST IMPORTANTLY
RESTORE FAITH IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BY PROVIDING RESPECTFUL
WELCOMING PATIENT SERVICE TO
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
STRUGGLING WITH LEGAL ISSUES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION. THANK YOU. STEPPED
IN. SHOP. IT IS YOUR PREFERRED
REGISTER SWITCH THE SECOND OF
MY IS. OKAY THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THE GOVERNOR HIS
PROPOSED BUDGET PROVIDE A POINT
MILLION FOR THAT FROM THE
GENERAL FOR AND FIFTH YEAR TWO
TWO ONE AND INCREASE TO FIFTY
FIVE FOR AND IN FISCAL YEAR TWO
ONE TO TWO TWO ESTABLISH A
CORDON PROGRAM IN THE TRI COURT.
THE CONCEPT COURT NOW NEVER IS
NOT NEW SEVERAL DO MODELS
FORMED ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
GENERALLY THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN VERY WELL RECEIVED BY
COURTS AND BY THE PUBLIC MY
COMMENTS TODAY WILL FOCUS ON
THE PROPOSED CAP COURT
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM AND HOW IT'S
COSTS AND BENEFITS WILL BE
ASSESSED. TO AVOID SUSTAINED
CHALLENGES THAT ARE EXPERIENCED
IN SOME MODELS THE NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM WOULD BE COURT
EMPLOYEES. NAVIGATORS WOULD
PROVIDE SERVICES REQUIRING NO
LEGAL TRAINING OR CREDENTIALS
EVERY EFFORT WOULD BE MADE FOR
SOMETHING WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY THE UNAUTHORIZED
PRACTICE OF LAW. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THE PROGRAM IS
NOT RESTRICTED TO SELF HELP
CENTERS ALTHOUGH CERTAINLY WE
CONTEMPLATE NAVIGATORS WOULD
HELP OUT THERE. NAVIGATORS
COULD BE DEPLOYED IN MANY COURT
LOCATIONS TO PROVIDE NON LEGAL
SUPPORT THAT FILLS GAPS IN
OTHER SERVICES THAT ADDRESS
PHYSICAL REMOTE OR EQUAL ACCESS
BARRIERS. FOR EXAMPLE
NAVIGATORS COULD PROVIDE
BRITAIN MARKED HIS MOVEMENTS
GETTING WRITTEN MATERIAL OR
STANDARD RESPONSES TO IN CRIER
IS BY PHONE EMAIL OR IN PERSON
IN THE SERVICES COULD HAPPEN
BEFORE THE LITIGANTS EVEN
APPEAR IN COURT SO THEY- KNOW
WHERE TO GO AND WHAT TO DO.
IT'S SAID THAT JUSTICE OFTEN
CALLS FOR SOMEONE TO JUST
LISTEN AND TRY TO HELP AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S THE CORE OF
WHAT WE'RE ENVISIONING IN THE
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM. WE'RE HOPING
NAVIGATORS WILL FACILITATE
PHYSICAL ACTS FOR ACCESS TO THE
COURTS WITH LOGISTICS WAY
FINDING ACCESSIBILITY RESOURCES
OR SIMPLY HELP HELPING PEOPLE
FIND WHERE THEY NEED TO GOAL OR
WHERE THE CHILDREN'S WAITING
ROOM MIGHT BE. NAVIGATORS COULD
PROMOTE LANGUAGE ACCESS
PREFERRED BY PROVIDING TRACK
THAT TRANSLATED MATERIALS AND
CONNECTION TO INTERPRETER
SERVICES. AND LOGISTICAL
SUPPORT FOR CASE COMPLETION AND
REFERRALS TO THAT DATE
LITIGANTS LEAVE THE COURT WITH
THEIR BUSINESS COMPLETELY
FINISHED. SPECIFICALLY WITHIN
SELF HELP CENTERS THE
NAVIGATORS WOULD PROVIDE NON
LEGAL SUPPORT AS DISTINCT FROM
THE WELL DEFINED LEGAL
ASSISTANCE OR LEGAL INFORMATION
SERVICES PROVIDE BY TRAIN SELF
HELP CENTER STAFF WERE BY
JUSTICE CORPS MEMBERS. IN THESE
TYPES OF THE NON LEGAL SERVICES
UP AT THE IF THEY WERE
AVAILABLE AT ALL COURTS ARE
OFTEN PERFORMED BY IF THE SORRY
IF THERE WHERE THEY ARE PER
PROVIDED IN THE COURTS THERE
OFTEN PERFORMED BY HIGHER LEVEL
PROFESSIONALS ARE AT. THE
EMPLOYEES WHOSE EXPERTISE IS IN
HIGH DEMAND AND SO ONE OF OUR
OBJECTIVES IS TO TRY TO MOVE IS
PART MUCH AS POSSIBLE OFF THE
PLATES OF THE PROFESSIONAL SO
THERE ARE MORE AVAILABLE TO
SERVE THE PUBLIC. THE COURT
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM IS DESIGNED
TO IMPROVE ACCESS SERVICES
ACROSS THE BOARD WITH SUPPORT
COMMUNICATION SHARED
INFORMATION. DATA AND TOOLS. SO
THE WAY WE CAN SEE THAT IS THAT
EACH COURT WOULD IDENTIFY ITS
SPECIIC ACCESS GAPS BECAUSE
COURTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT AS WE DISCUSSED
ALREADY. AND THAT COURT WOULD
MAKE AN APPLICATION FOR THE
MODEL THAT THEY WANT TO
IMPLEMENT IDENTIFYING WITH THE
NAVIGATOR WOULD DO AND I AND
OTHER SPECIFICS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM. THE RECORD TO RECEIVE
ONGOING INFORMATION TOOLS AND
TECHNICAL SUPPORT FOR PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION AND FOR SERVICE
IMPROVEMENT AND I THINK THAT
ANOTHER PIECE OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS ON GOING IMPROVEMENT TO
LEARN AND JUST AS IS
CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE. AN ONLINE
NAVIGATOR NAPA NOT  NETWORK
WOULD ALSO BE CREATED SO THAT
COURTS COULD COMMUNICATE ONLINE
WITH EACH OTHER AND SHARE IDEAS
AND IT WOULD BE A PLACE FOR
PEOPLE TO SEE TO LOG WITH
SUGGESTIONS AND GIVE FEEDBACK.
A PROGRAM ARCHIVE WOULD ALSO
HOUSE MATERIALS AVAILABLE TO
ALL COURTS THAT WERE DEVELOPED
BY ANY ONE OF THEM. SO THERE
MIGHT BE OFF THE SHELF PROGRAM
RESOURCES TRAINING CURRICULA
AND OTHER MATERIALS. THE
PROGRAM MOST IMPORTANTLY WILL
USE DATA TO ADVICE OPERATIONAL
DECISIONS AND SHARE INNOVATIONS
WITH COUNTIES AND STATES. COST
DATA WOULD BE AVAILABLE FROM
THE FINANCIAL RECORDS OF THE
PROGRAM SERVICE METRICS WOULD
BE LOGGED ON HAND HELD DEVICES
ISSUED TO EACH NAVIGATOR SO
THAT WE COULD GET REAL TIME
REPORTS ON THE TYPE OF SERVICE
THE NUMBER OF LITIGANTS SERVED
THE TIME SPENT AND WHETHER
PROGRESS IS MADE TOWARD
COMPLETION OF THE COURT MATTER.
WE NOW RIGHT DID A POINT WHERE
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
UPLOAD THAT DATA AND MAKE IT
AVAILABLE BOTH TO THE PROGRAM
OTHER COURTS AND IN TO THE TO
THE COURTS. OF HAVE REAL TIME
TO. NAVIGATORS WOULD BE. TO
DRAW FOR THE FROM THEIR GREAT
ON THE GROUND A- AND MAKES A-
FOR. THESE IDEAS TRANSMITTED ON
THEIR HAND HELD DEVICES OR TO
SUBMITTED THROUGH THE NAVIGATOR
NETWORK COULD BE FED BACK TO
THE COURTS. CUSTOMERS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS SATISFACTION
ASSESSMENTS WOULD ALSO BE
CRITICAL SO WE COULD BEGIN TO
ADJUST THE SERVICES TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM. THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WILL STRIVE
FOR INNOVATION IN INFORMATION
SHARING TO DEVELOP NAVIGATOR
SERVICES THAT MAKE A
DEMONSTRABLE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
ATTENTION. THANK YOU AND THEN
FINAL MEMBER THE PANEL JUDGE
BRAZIL. PRESIDING JUDGE OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH MUST BE
PRETTY EASY TO DO HOUSE IN
ORDER AND THEN IN YOUR SPARE
TIME YOUR ALSO CO CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL COMMITTEE ON
ACCESS AND FAIRNESS YES I THINK
YOU HAVE A LOT TO OFFER TO
TODAY THANK YOU. WELL GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE YOUR
WOMAN WEBER AND SIMPLY MEMBER
AND READY JONES SAWYER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KEVIN BRAZIL IN THE
PRESIDING JUDGE OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT. I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO SHOWCASE THE SELF HELP
PROGRAMS WE OFFER LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. BEFORE
I GET INTO THE SPECIFIC I'D
LIKE TO SHOW YOU A SHORT VIDEO
WHICH IGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF SELF HELP. FOR UNREPRESENTED
LITIGANTS. THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
ARE MINORITIES ESPECIALLY
LATINO ASIAN AFRICAN AMERICAN.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF JUDGES
AND SELF HELP CENTER STAFF IN
OUR COURT HOUSE. GOING TO COURT
INITIALLY ARE EVEN ONGOING IS
VERY INTIMIDATING. ON BECAUSE
FIRST OF ALL YOU'RE NOT AN
ATTORNEY BUT AS- A SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS YOU ARE
HELL TO SOMEWHAT THAT STANDARD
I SAW MY OWN FAMILY GO THROUGH
OUR OWN LEGAL BATTLES AND I SAW
JUST HOW. STRESSFUL IT WAS FOR
THEM SELF HELP IS IT I FEEL
WITH EDUCATIONAL WE HAVE FIRST
HAND KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT THE
COURTS REQUIREMENTS ARE
PROCEDURALLY HOW TO DRAFT
PEOPLE WORK WHICH CAN BE VERY
CUMBERSOME AND VERY CONFUSING
WE PROVIDE SERVICES REALLY TO
ANYONE WHO NEEDS IT. WE DON'T
JUST TURN PEOPLE AWAY BASED ON
THEIR INCOME STATUS WE'RE ALSO
ABLE TO OFFER SERVICES IN MANY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES ONE THE
GAME WAS AFRAID TO COME TO
COURT BECAUSE- SHE WAS NO
LONGER THE CUSTODIAL PARENT.
AND A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAPPENED AND SHE WAS JUST
AFRAID TO GO BACK BEFORE THE
COURT. AND SO I HELPED HER-
FORMULATE HER PAPERWORK IN HER
DOCUMENTS IN HER DECLARATION.
AND SHE'S LITERALLY NO
EXAGGERATION SHE CRIED SHE
REALLY CRIED BECAUSE SHE SAID
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN HERE IS
WHAT I'VE BEEN TRYING TO SAVE
FOR THE PAST I THINK IT WAS
FIVE YEARS. NICE TO SEE IT FROM
THE BEGINNING OR YOU'RE TIMID
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON TO THIS AND POWER- UTILITY
SO IT'S REALLY NICE. TO SEE
THAT TRANSFORMATION OCCUR I
THINK THE ENTIRE PURPOSE OF
SELF HELP REALLY AND BODIES THE
COURTS MENTION OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. SO I LA COUNTY WE'RE
LAW. SO IS YOU CAN SEE ON THE
WE WE'VE GOT TWELVE DISTRICTS.
AND HERE THE STARS THEIR SHOW
OUR SELF HELP CENTERS WHERE
THEY'RE LOCATED THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY PRIMARILY CONCENTRATED
IN THE MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREAS. WE'VE GOT TO OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY LANGUAGES
THAT ARE SPOKEN- THE LARGEST
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO NEED SELF
HELP OR LATINO ASIAN AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN- WE HAVE
THIRTY NINE COURTHOUSES. AND
ALMOST SIX HUNDRED VENTURE
OFFICERS SO THE OPERATION IS
HUGE AND THE NEED FOR SELF HELP
IS ENORMOUS AND WE TRY TO
PROVIDE THAT THROUGH THE MANY
SELF HELP CENTERS THAT WE HAVE
TO ROUTE OR COUNTY. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS WE TALK ABOUT WHEN
WE WERE DRESSING SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS WHO NEED
THE SELF HELP. IS WHAT SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE THERE'S PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS THERE'S LEGAL SERVICE
AGENCIES LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
HAVE NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL
SERVICES. THE HANDLE OF THE
UNLAWFUL DETAINER MATTERS WE
HAVE THAT STATIC WE ALSO HAVE
THE STRIVE A PROGRAM WHICH ALSO
HAD REPRESENTS. PEOPLE WHO HAVE
UNLAWFUL DETAINER MATTERS AND
THOSE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES IF YOU LOSE
AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER YOUR
HOMELESS. AND WE HAVE A LARGE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN LA
COUNTY. SO IN TERMS OF. THE
SELF HELP NEEDS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE CAPACITY OF
THE LITIGANT- OFTENTIMES THE
LITIGANTS HAVE. MIDDLE WHAT
AMOUNT OF EDUCATION AND MAY
HAVE MENTAL ILLNESS SO WE HAVE
TO TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT. THE
CASE COMPLEXITY IS ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT AND THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE LEGAL ISSUES THAT CAN
RANGE FROM A DIVORCE ALL THE
WAY TO A CONSERVATORSHIP. SO
THAT THE ISSUES ARE QUITE
CHALLENGING. BUT WE MANAGE AND
AGAIN I THINK A LOT OF THAT.
WITH ALLOWS US TO MANAGE IT SO
WELL IT'S A GREAT STAFF THAT WE
HAVE. SO JUST WANT TO TALK
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR SELF HELP
CENTER FUNDING WHAT THEY DO- WE
HAVE BILINGUAL STAFF- WE HAVE A
MID FOURTEEN COURT HOUSES- THEY
COLLABORATE. WITH OTHER. LEGAL
SERVICE AGENCIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- I APPLAUD THE WORK
OF THE LA COUNTY LIBRARY THEY
ARE LIVE LEE LOCATED ACROSS THE
STREET. FROM MY COURTHOUSE SO%
WE SEE THEM- AS ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO. SO IN TERMS OF. AS I
SAID. THE SPECTRUM OF SERVICES-
THIS IS GIVE YOU SOME OF THE
NUMBERS- THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IN LA COUNTY WHICH ARE
HUGE- BUT AGAIN IT'S A LARGE
COUNTY TEN MILLION PEOPLE- SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE. AND WE SEE IT AS A AS A
TEAM EFFORT. AND THAT INVOLVES
ALL OF US THE COUNTY LIBRARIES
YOU PROVIDING US THE FUNDING
THAT BENCH OFFICERS AND THE
COURT STAFF WE MAKE IT WORK. SO
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE
HAVE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
LANGUAGE ACCESS AS THE SLIDE
EARLIER SHOWED THE EARLIER
SLIDE SHOWED WE HAVE SO MANY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES SPOKEN-
SPANISH IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S IMPORTANT- AND I'M GOING
TO TALK ABOUT IT A BIT IS THE
JUSTICE CORPS. AND HOW WE
OPERATE THAT PROGRAM WE HAVE A
LOT OF BILINGUAL STAFF AND
STUDENTS. WHO HELPED TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE- SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
RECOGNIZE BUT THE HARDEST THING
TO DO. IS IF YOU GO IN A COURT
ROOM AND YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE LANGUAGE. IMAGINE YOURSELF
IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY. BEING
PLACED IN A FOREIGN SYSTEM AND
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE LANGUAGE. THAT IS SO
CRITICAL SO WE TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT THROUGH OUR SELF HELP
PROGRAM. ONE OF THE THINGS WE
ALSO DO IS WE HAVE ONLINE
SERVICES. AND WE HAVE MANY MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS FROM TRAFFIC
CITATIONS TO HELPING THEM WITH
THE FORCE WE HAVE KIND OF A
GUIDE AND FILE SYSTEM WHERE
THE- YOU WALKING THROUGH AND-
THE YOUNG LADY TO MY LEFT
THAT'S OUR FAVORITE EMPLOYEE
GINA. HELP YOU. AND SHE- WILL.
BE SO OF DIFFERENT. SO YOU
MIGHT WANT OKAY JACK CHILL
TODAY. SO ALSO WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT THE JUSTICE
CORPORATE IT'S BEEN AN EGG.
SINCE TWO. FOUR IT'S IN LAW
ANGELES COUNTY DIEGO. TO BEAR.
AND BASICALLY WHAT WE HAVE THE-
ARE CARL STUDENTS. WHO WORK AT
OUR SELF HELP CENTERS AND THEY
DO CLASSES THEY WALKED THE
PEOPLE THROUGH IN TERMS OF
FILLING OUT THE FORMS. SHOWING
THEM WHERE THE COURT ROOM IS.
KIND OF PRETTY MUCH GUIDING
THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS- WE
LIKE TO CALL THEM BLUESHIRTS
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE OF. THE
YOUNGSTERS IN THE BLUESHIRTS
THAT'S HOW WE IDENTIFY HIM
THROUGHOUT THE COURT. SO IF YOU
EVER DOWN IN LOS ANGELES COME
ON INTO THE MáS COURTHOUSE
RHYME MATTER ANY OF OUR- OTHER
CENTERS AND YOU'LL SEE ALL THE
BLUESHIRTS. WALKING THROUGH THE
CORRIDORS OF THE COURTHOUSE BUT
THEY'RE THERE TO HELP PEOPLE-
AND A LOT OF THEM COME BACK
SOME OF THE MOVE EVEN GOT ON TO
BE LAWYERS SO. IT'S A GOOD
EXPERIENCE- IT HELPS THEM INTO
THE OF LEADERSHIP. SOME OF THE
CIVIL THAT WE FOR IN CELL HELP.
MAINLY REALLY YOU WANT IMPAIR
PEOPLE KIND OF WHAT THE- TALK
ABOUT THIS PEOPLE COME THE CO.
AND THEY CAN BUT- TO CAN BE CAN.
SO SELF HELP IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE IF YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING YOU CAN MUCH.
BETTER EXCEPT THE RESULT. SO WE
TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN LA
COUNTY WITH OUR SELF HELP
SERVICES. WE HAVE A LOT OF
GREAT PEOPLE. WHO HELP US TO DO
IT. OUR STAFF. JUSTICE FOR
PEOPLE AND WE ARE VERY VERY
GRATEFUL. SO ONE SIZE AS WE
SAID DOESN'T FIT ALL BUT I HOPE
THAT YOU CAN RECOGNIZE THAT IN
REGARDS TO SELF HELP- WE BUILT
OVER A BUS AND EXPENSE OF SELF
HELP SYSTEM THANKS IN PART TO
YOUR FOR SITE. AND FINDING. AND
CONTINUED PRIORITIZATION OF
SELF HELP. AS A RESULT OF OUR
PROGRAMS LITIGANTS ARE COMING
TO COURT PREPARED AND I CAN'T
STRESS. ENOUGH BEING PREPARED
BECAUSE WHEN THEY'RE-UNPREPARED. IT DELAYS THINGS IN
THE LAKE BECAUSE THIS MONEY
DOESN'T IT HURTS US AS A CORE
IN TERMS OF BEING EFFICIENT.
HAVING PEOPLE TO COME TO COME
BACK SOME PEOPLE ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS A PROBLEM SO
SEC PUBLISHED. TO MAKING SURE
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
ACTUALLY HAS MEETING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. SO HAVING SEEN THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE NAVIGATORS
AND- ESPECIALLY WITH WITH THE
FOLKS HERE AT. AT THE TABLE
BECAUSE IT'S LAW LIBRARY SELF
HELP CENTERS AND OTHERS. HOW
DOES ALL THIS FIT TOGETHER SO
THAT WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING
SERVICES AND THAT THAT WE
PROVIDE THIS THIS CONTINUOUS
ABILITY TO COORDINATE ALL OF
THIS ACROSS THE BOARD. AND THEN
FROM WITH WHAT JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IS LOOKING AT A THINK THAT'S
KIND OF PART PARCEL TO THIS. SO
IT IS AS WE LOOK AT A SYSTEM
THAT HAS DEVELOPED OVER TIME.
BECAUSE OF THE NEED WHICH IS
GREAT BUT HOW DO WE- FORMALISE
THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE SERVICES ACROSS ALL OF
OUR COUNTIES LA BEING LITTLE
FORGES COURTS. PROBABLY IN THE
COUNTRY WE ARE YEAH I WITH THAT
WOULD EXPECT SO. WHICH HAS ITS
OWN CHALLENGES ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO SOME OF OUR MORE RURAL
COUNTIES WHERE ACCESS IS AS
IMPORTANT WITH SOME THE
DISTANCES PEOPLE HAVE TO TRAVEL
THE WAY THAT THAT. THE COURTS
ARE SPREAD OUT. HOWDO WE HAVE
THIS COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER THAT WE'RE NOT
NOW DUPLICATING THAT WERE
MANAGING AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL.
YEAH THANK DEAL WITH NEXT. WITH
THE NAVIGATORS IT'S JUST BY A
THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND. LOOK
AT YOUR SAID. MANY OF THE
PROGRAM WILL HAVE A WILL JUST
JUST FOUND. ON GAVE SEGUE FAN
PROPOSED PROBABLY CAN'T TAKE
THAT THE SCALE BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF A COMMUNITY
CAL COLLABORATION WE GET GREAT
BENEFIT FROM AS WELL- SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THE
WITH THE NAVIGATORS IS ASK EACH
COURT TO LOOK AT THEIR SYSTEM
AS A SYSTEM. AND TO LOOK AT IT
WE'RE IS HELP NEEDED AND WHERE
IS IT THE RIGHT MATCH BETWEEN
THE CREDENTIALS OF
QUALIFICATIONS OF THE HELPERS
AND THE NEEDS OF THE OF THE
LITIGANTS IF THEY MAKE A
PROPOSAL IS A BUSINESS PROPOSAL
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
WITH NAVIGATORS. THEN WE START
GIVING THEM ALL THE SUPPORT CAN
AND CONNECTING THEM SO THAT
THEY CAN TALK TO EACH OTHER WE
HOPE THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT'S
RICH IN IDEAS. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE NOT DURING WHAT
HAD. I'M COULD WHO SERVE HOW
MANY. AND GET THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AGAIN FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROVIDING THIS
RECESS WERE THEY RECOMMEND SO
WE THINK THAT MIGHT STARTING
THE GROUND AND TRACKING AND
COMMUNICATING WITH. BE ABLE TO
COME WITH THE BEST ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION THE TRUTH IS WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER DO YOU TO
IN THE LAW LIBRARY LAW
LIBRARIES ARE SORT OF FUND
SEPARATELY. KIND OF LOOK
THAT'LL BIT TO. THE SELF HELP
SO ARE PART OF THE COURTS I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALL
LOOKING AT ALL THE COMPONENTS
AND TYING THEM INAPPROPRIATELY
SO SINCE I'M REPRESENTING
WALLER HELPED TACKLE THAT WENT.
IN SOME WAYS I THINK OUR ANSWER
TO THIS QUESTION IS EASIER THAN
FOR SOME OF THE OTHER AGENCIES
BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY THE GAL
FOR. HANDLE WHAT ELSE DUCKS SO
WHAT'S IN TO US IS THE CAN.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT
WHAT'S BEING HANDLED HIMSELF
HELP WORK PREFERRED WITH SELF
CENTER WITH BEING HANDLED BY
PLAYED WHERE REFERRED DELAY.
BUT WHAT THEY'RE NOT. OUR WITH
IN STATE COURT ISSUES MORE CA.
SELECT OR UNIQUE PIECES WERE
LEGAL RESTRICTIONS REQUIRED.
AND THAT OF THING IT'S NOT FORM
BAY. BUT ALSO OUTSIDE OF STAY.
COURTS THERE ARE. IN THE- CORE
THERE ADMIN. COURT THERE ARE.
COURTS AND YOU GO BY. THAT TO
NON COURT REALLY ISSUE ARE
THINGS THAT WE HOPE WILL NEVER
GET COURT. OF DISPUTE THAT ARE
HOW. WITH LAND LOW TENANT. OVER.
GOOD GOVERNMENT CAN CREDIT HOW
TO START A BUSINESS THERE'S
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN THAT
IS A LEGAL ISSUE THE LIST OF
LEGAL ISSUES IN IN THE- FOLDERS
THAT THAT WE HANDED UP FROM THE
LAW LIBRARIES- ON THE BACK OF
ONE OF THOSE PAGES THERE'S A
LIST. THAT THE SAMPLING FOR ONE
WEEK AT COUNTY LAW LIBRARY SO
SOME OF THE TOPICS THAT CAME IN
AND YOU'LL SEE IT'S ALL ACROSS
THE BOARD AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE
WILL HANDLE ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING SO WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT TO US IS THE
COMMUNICATION THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE COURTS AND- IN LA I CAN SAY
IT'S WONDERFUL WE- WILL. WORK
WELL WITH OUR OUR COURT IN OUR
SELF HELP CENTER AND WE KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE HANDLING AND AS
THIS OF HELP CENTER EXPAND TO
MORE CIVIL WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
HAPPEN. BUT BEACH JUST THAT CAN
YOU TO KNOW THEY'RE HANDLING
BECAUSE ITS CONFUSING FOR US
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE CLIENTS
RIGHT THE LITIGANTS THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS MAYBE THEY
CAN'T EVEN RECOGNIZE THE LEGAL
ISSUE WAS DISCUSSED BEFORE BUT
IF THEY DO RECOGNIZE IT'S A
LEGAL ISSUE. THEY DON'T KNOW
AND WALL UPGRADE LIBRARIES IN
GENERAL ARE SORT OF A TRUST
BRING. PEOPLE UNDER. THAT LIFE
HOW. AND COME TO US IN M. I'VE
GOT THIS ISSUE I THINK IT LEGAL
SHOULD I BE. AND IF WE HAVE ALL
THE AND- ABOUT WHAT EVERYBODY
ELSE IS DOING THEN WE CAN ALL
THERE'S A- FOR YOU THE
COURTHOUSE OR THERE'S A- IN
LEGAL A- OR WE SAY NO. GOT SELF
HELP AND HE HELPS AND WILL BE
THREAT AND IF YOU. SEE AND- YOU
KNOW IN PACKED AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE GIVE THEM TO THEM THE
PROP AS. FOR US WE'RE.
FORMATION THAT THEY HAVE THEN
WE CAN BUILD ON THAT- AND-
CAPTURE THE REST OF IT. AND
THAT'S GREAT AND IT SHOULD WE
AND JUDGE BECAUSE YOU'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SUGGEST COUNSEL
BUT ALSO TRYING TO MANAGE A
COURT. ARE THE THINGS WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING HARDER AT FROM RULES
AND PROCEDURES AND OTHERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZING. AND
WHERE WE'VE COME WITH THE
REALITY IS. ONE OF THE THINGS
WE DO AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DOES IS THEY TRY TO MAKE THE
FORMS EASIER AND SIMPLER TO
FOLLOW BECAUSE- ESPECIALLY. FOR
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THESE FORMS AND
YOU. JUST CAN'T UNDERSTAND IT.
SO WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TRYING TO
MAKE THE FORMS. EASY TO
UNDERSTAND I CALL IT SIMPLE
ENGLISH. SO THAT WHEN YOU READ
IT IT MAKES SENSE IT'S NOT
LEGAL JARGON THAT PEOPLE JUST
REALLY HAVE A HARD TIME
FOLLOWING. SO WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME DOING THAT AND WORKING
WITH. THE COUNTY LAW LIBRARY
THERE ARE PARTNER AND WE LOOK
TO THEM TO HELP US WITH THESE
FORMS AND- PUT THESE FORMS OUT
FOR A CUP PUBLIC COMMENT.
BEFORE WE ADOPT THE RULES BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL SO THAT WE
HAVE CLEAR FORMS THAT'S WHY FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE GUIDING FILE
WERE YOU GO ONLINE AND- I
SHOWED YOU ARE EMPLOYED
JEANETTE SHE WALKS YOU THROUGH
THE FORM. OF A LOT OF TIMES
IT'S DIFFICULT FROM LEGAL
ASPECT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE PHRASEOLOGY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE TERMS. YOU
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT CERTAIN
THE MEANING. OF WEEK SIMPLIFY
IT AND IF YOU GO ON OUR WEBSITE
THEY'LL BASICALLY ASK YOU GIVE
YOU PROPS CERTAIN QUESTIONS. SO
YOU KNOW HOW TO HANDLE IT
BECAUSE IT'S ALL ABOUT. JUST
UNDERSTANDING IN ITS HEART I
MEAN I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL FOR
YEARS I'VE BEEN A- GOOD FROM
TWENTY SO AND I SEE DON'T HAVE
THE ANSWERS. SO SOMEONE WOULD
NEVER BEEN THE LAW SCHOOL EVEN
CALL OR MAYBE GRABBED HIGH
SCHOOL IT'S AND- DIFFICULT VERY
CONFUSING. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS BASED
ON. ADVERSE HE'S. IT'S ALL. ON
UP THAT IF YOU DON'T GET
EVERYTHING A- RIGHT. A BECOME
SORT OF A GOTCHA FOR THE SIDE.
CAN HAVE NOW YOU HAVE A
UNREPRESENTED LITIGANTS. WHO A
LEGITIMATE. THE HE DOES THEY
DON'T KNOW. THE JAR THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND. THE CASE OUGHT AND
WHY. THAT WORDING IS DONE EXACT
THE WAY THAT IS THAT THEN
BECOMES A GOTCHA TO SOMEBODY
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO TRAP. IN
THAT SITUATION RIGHT IN AS THAT
IS THE REALITY THAN LAWYERS WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TRYING TO
MAKE SURE IT'S LEGALLY PROPER
THE FORMS. THAT THE PROCESS IS
FAIR THAT THE PROCESS WORKS.
BUT MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS THAT AND HOW THEY
FIT IN. AND WHAT THEY NEED TO
SAY AND GET IT RIGHT. THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE AND THAT'S WHERE
ALL OF US HAVE TO WORK AS A
TEAM. MA'AM GOOD DOCTOR WEB
MA'AM YOU'RE JUST WANTED TO-
AND I IT'S AN AS A AS I'M LIST
BECAUSE I THINK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT MATTER IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE IS VERY CLEAR FOR THE
LAY PERSON VERSUS BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN IN SITUATIONS WHERE. THE
PERSON DID NOT UNDERSTAND. AND
THEY SPOKE ENGLISH THEY JUST
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THE
TERMINOLOGY USED BY THE LAWYER
OR THE JUDGE- WAS JUST SO
DIFFERENT AND SOMETIMES LAWYERS
GET IN A CIRCLE NOW TALK THE
SAME THING I WAS MAYOR TO ONCE
THEY ALL. GOT THE SAME THING.
AND I'VE DONE A LOT OF
INTERPRETATION FOR MY KIDS SO
THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
FATHER WAS SAYING WHEN THEY
WERE LITTLE. BUT IT'S A IT'S A
DIFFICULT- YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THEY TALK TO EACH OTHER JUST
DIFFICULT FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IS VERY CLEAR TO THEM.
SO I'M GLAD THAT THERE'S A
DISCUSSION OF THAT BECAUSE THAT
IS SOMETIMES THE GREATEST BERRY
WE THINK. SB KEYS BECAUSE
EVERYONE'S QUOTE SPEAKS ENGLISH
THAT THEY REALLY UNDERSTAND AND
THEY DON'T. AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS WE TRY TO DO ON THE
PROVIDING ACCESS AND PARENTS
COMMITTEES AND LOOK AT THESE
FORMS. AND SAY YOU KNOW CAN THE
AVERAGE PERSON WHO HAS AMEND
THE LAW SCHOOL HAS A- MINIMAL
AMOUNT OF EDUCATION UNDERSTAND.
HOW TO GET FROM QUEST AND WANT
TO QUESTION FIFTEEN. ON THIS
FORM THANKS THEY CAN THEN THE
FORM NOT WORKING YEAH SO WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON. HOW
DIVERSE IS THE POPULATION OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU HAVE
WORKING AND ALL THAT SO FOR
JUSTICE COURT FOR. ALL THE
MAJORITY OF THE K ÁI
COLUMN KIDS BUT- COLLEGE- ARE
LATINO HISPANIC. WE HAVE ABOUT
I THINK IT'S ABOUT THIRTY SOME
ODD PERCENT. OF THE THREE
HUNDRED. LATINO HISPANIC
THERE'S ABOUT ANOTHER. AT
FIFTEEN AND 19% OF ASIAN ABOUT
5010% AFRICAN AMERICAN. AND WE
KIND OF WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS WE
TRY TO. GET PEOPLE. IN JUSTICE
CORPS WHO LOOK LIKE THE PEOPLE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DRIVING.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW ACCESS. IN
MAKING THINGS MEANINGFUL IT'S
ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT EASIER WHEN
YOU SEE SOMEBODY WHO LOOKS LIKE
YOU. WHETHER IT'S A JUDGE OF
ATTORNEY- SOMEONE WHO'S HELPING
YOU AT A SELF CENTER. IT MAKES
A DIFFERENCE SO WHEN YOU COME
THE LA YOU'LL SEE. WE HAVE A
LOT OF DIVERSITY. I LIKE TO
CALL IT WE GOT GREAT INCLUSION.
BECAUSE THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. THAT MAKES IT.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE MMHM. TO HAVE THAT
SO WEEKS WORK VERY HARD. WHEN
WE'RE PICKING OUR OWN COURT
STAFF. I KNOW I DO IT WHEN I'M
PICKING JUDGES. GOING CERTAIN
COMMITTEES THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
LOOK LIKE. THE PEOPLE YOU SERVE.
AND MOST OF FRAZIER SERVING OUR
AND BROWN. BLACK AND BROWN I
MEAN LET ME KNOW THE LAW. POPPY
IN HERE I CAN. FOLLOWED BY A- I
THEN AND ARE IN THE- BUT I MEAN
THE ONES THAT ARE INTO CO WAS
THAT ARE. IN THE MASS THE
POPULAR THE MUCH. ARE LATINO
AFRICAN. AGE OKAY WE MAINLY SO.
THAT PROBABLY TO THIRDS. OF WHO
WE HAVE TO HELP. AND THEY'RE
PROBABLY. I MEAN THEY'RE
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS OF
HIM WITH HER ILL. SO THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
DIVERSITY AMONG OUR STAFF. AND
DIVERSITY IN THE JUSTICE CORPS
MEMBERS AND QUITE FRANKLY WHAT
WE HAVE DIVERT. ON OUR BENCH.
OKAY OKAY ARE GOOD. I ASK THE
QUESTION BECAUSE I GET OF. I IN
OUR WORLD WE GIVE CAUGHT UP IN
MAKING SURE THAT ALL THE
LANGUAGE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED.
AT OF A LOT OF AFRICAN.
CONSTITUENTS WERE ANGRY BECAUSE
THEY GO AND THEY SEE NO ONE
THAT LOOKS LIKE THEM IN SOME
COURTS AND MAYBE NOT IN LA. BUT
THE OTHER PLACES IN AND PEOPLE
SAY BUT WE HAVE TO MEET THE
LANGUAGE NEEDS. AND AS A RESULT
IN MILLIMETERS L<c.cyan>G NEEDS TO.</c>
ALIENATED LEFT OUT EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE PROBABLY. PERCENT
PEOPLE SHOWING UP IN COURT IN
SOME AREAS A MORE RIGHT THAT
THEY FEEL LIKE THERE'S NO ON
THE LIKE THEM. WE'VE GOT TO
MEET THE L<c.cyan>G IN THE YET</c>
THOSE ALL HAVE A SO. NUMBER OF
LÏNG YOU NEED TO. OF WHAT WE
CALL IN FOR. RIGHT OF VERSES
DID JUST ENGLISH SO THAT
BECOMES A MAJOR SO. JUST WANNA
SURE WHAT KIND OF. AWARE OF
THAT AS WE TO ABOUT. JEFF AND
PEOPLE FEEL. GOOD WHEN THEY
COME IN WHEN THEY LEAVE. YEAH
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO. AND GOT
THE- THAT THEY THOUGHT THEY
HAVE ME I ALWAYS. YOU KNOW
DIVERSE INCLUDES IS SORT. AND
THAT'S WHY. WE HAVE THE
PROVIDING A- AND FOR COMMITTEE
TO MAKE. THEIR HOME OF THE
JUDICIAL. BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
THE- COME UP WILL DO YOU MEAN.
WHAT IS VERSUS INCLUSION IS NOT
MENTIONING. THE CHANCE OF TO.
THE CURRENT AND THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING. AND MAKING
SHORT THAT EQUAL. TO JUSTICE ME
SOMETHING. AND PURSE. IS
REALITY PEOPLE WHO ARE SO IF
YOU DON'T PURSUE. THE. BETTER
YOU OR YOUR HAD. YOU AOUT YOU
WERE LOOK LIKE A- ARE A- YOU
THE- TO YOU FOR. LIKE WHILE
HAVE AND JUSTICE. YOU MAY HAVE.
BUT THE PER. IS YOU DID NOT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE TRY. HARD WITH.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LOOK FOR TO SEE YOU GUYS
OBVIOUSLY THE BUDGET. AS WELL.
MR YOU WANTED TO I JUST WANTED
TO OUT. THIS WAS MENTION
JUSTICE FAIR AND SO INTENTIONS.
THAT THE FACT THAT WE CAN.
MONDAY THROUGH. AND SEE SERVE.
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THE THAT A
LUG FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS BUT IN
OTHER COUNTIES WERE ONE
FACILITATOR WHEN SELF HELP. THE
STAFF ATTORNEY MUST BOUNCE
BETWEEN DIFFERENT COUNTIES
THAT. THAT ISN'T REALLY
FAIRNESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO WE WANT TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHAT IT'S THE BEST PRACTICE
WHAT OF THE MODEL PROGRAMS. AND
TRY TO GET THAT TO EVERY COUNTY
IN IN CALIFORNIA. SEVEN SEVEN
POINT THANK YOU. INTO YOUR POOR.
DOES RESULT. ABOUT THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE DIVERSITY THAT'S
GREAT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BENCH OF THE BAR IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PIPELINE LEADING INTO
THE LEGAL PROFESSION. WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO TO HAVE A LONG
ROAD OUR PROFESSION THAT WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS ARE MAKING PRIZES BUT
THERE'S LOTS. DO AND WE'RE
GOING TO HELP. THREE ONE. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE OF PRESSURE
NEEDS TO LIKE CALIFORNIA DOES
GONNA END THERE THOUGH. BALLOTS
THANK YOU YOUR WORK IN LA BUT
YEAH HAVE CROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SOME. SO I'M NOT
GONNA OPEN UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT
WE HAVE SELENA COPELAND AND
JASMINE COULD OR A- AND IF
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS. THESE COMMITTEES THIS
HEARING. ON THIS TOPIC PLEASE
COME FORWARD. AND WE HAVE A
BACK PHONE IN THE MIDDLE THAT.
IS AVAILABLE. THANK YOU. I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF BECAUSE
I REALIZE READ THE NOON HOUR
I'M FEELING A COUPLE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND I
WANTED TO THINK- CHAIR STONE OF
COURSE DOCTOR WEBER FOR YOUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA. I AM. SO
LACK OF THE OVER ONE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE FREE
LEGAL SERVICES TO LONG
CALIFORNIANS WHETHER THEY'RE
FUNDED BY THE STATE BAR. AND
ALSO THOSE THAT DON'T RECEIVE
STATE BAR FUNDING. AND WHILE WE
BELIEVE THAT FUNDING FOR
INCREASED REPRESENTATION IS OF
COURSE OF THE HIGHEST
IMPORTANCE. AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE- ACCESS
PROBLEM IS MUCH BIGGER. AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS TODAY
FROM ALL THE PANELISTS
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL COURT RESOURCES.
INCLUDING AT ACCESS
INTERPRETERS IN COURT
REPORTERS. AND ALSO THE MENTION
THE LAST PANEL ABOUT THE NEED
FOR. AN IMPROVED COURT
PROCESSES AND IMPROVE COURT
FORMS THERE'S JUST A LOT THAT.
A REGULAR LITIGATE CANNOT%
UNDERSTAND UNLESS AN ATTORNEY.
TO REPRESENT SO YOU JUST CAN'T.
NEED TO SOME. PROCESSES THE
LAWYERS ARE NOT. TO NAVIGATE
THE LEGAL SYSTEM. TO THE
BACKGROUND PAPER OF COURSE I AM
VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND HAVE
LITTLE TO ADD OTHER THAN
WISHING TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE. OF COLLABORATION
AND HIS BODY SAID IN A PRIOR
PANEL PRIOR TO THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN THERE WAS A LOT MORE.
COORDINATION A LOT MORE
OFFICIAL COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION THAT HAPPENED AND
WHEN FUNDING SHRUNK A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS AGENCIES TURNED
ON THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO-
WORK ON THEIR OWN STAFFING IN
THEIR OWN CLIENT SERVICES. AND
WE HAVE NOT YET READ THE TIME
WERE WERE CLASS. REALLY THE
OTHER. AND I WOULD. THE DOES
CAN INCREASED FIVE. SO AS THIS
TO COMMIT WORK INCREASE.
FUNDING FOR JUST A SYSTEM THINK
THE CALL. WILL CONTINUE AND I
THINK ANY BRIDGMAN. AN
IMPORTANT. AND THEN I JUST. FOR
THE GET THE BOAT IS TO FIND.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING I'M I
AM JAZZMAN OR OVER THE CAL
COMMISSION ON ACCESS TO I'M
STATUS WHEN IT I'D WEBER TERMS
TO AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE OF THE
ACCESS COMMISSION A YOU MAY
KNOW HAS WORKED COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE LAWYER AND OTHERS ON
THIS ISSUE FOR OVER YEARS I'M
SORRY I JUST WANT TO CALL IT TO
COUPLE OF CRITICAL ISSUES TODAY
THE FIRST IS A CHALLENGE THAT
LIE IN RIGHT. IN THE WORLD CUP
FACE AND OBTAIN ACCESS TO AND
SERVICES FOR THEIR LEGAL
PROBLEMS THE ACCESS COMMISSION
RECENTLY PRODUCED THREE PAPERS
ROW ISSUES WE WILL BE WITH YOU
ARE ELECT. I'M THIS IS THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THE LIBRARIES
HAVE DISASTERS SUCH AS
EARTHQUAKES AND WILDFIRES WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFICULTY THING
LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF WORKING TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR CAPACITIES AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE LIKE TO SEIZE. ALRIGHT CNN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
ALL THE PANEL. FOR SO GOOD
INFORMATION WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK BUT AS- SO I APPRECIATE
THAT. WE ARE NOW JR.